Brian,
Brian.
that's a good God damn fucking song.
Brian,
do you like it?
You know how to pick Mike Posner?
Mike Posner.
This is the guy who became famous over
the Internet.
Yes.
Wow,
that's pretty good.
We got aol instant messenger going on in
the background or something.
I don't know what it is.
Ladies and gentlemen,
thank you very much once again for
tuning in to the,
to the podcast.
As always,
we're sponsored by fleshlight.
My special guest today is Rick
Schroeder.
Ladies,
gentlemen,
Rick Schroeder from a million different
things.
The first time I was ever exposed to
you.
I was a little kid and um,
my step father took me to see the champ
and I cried like a bitch.
Real.
Oh,
lots of good stories.
I'm remaking that.
Are you doing it again?
Really in the world?
Hopefully your world in the MMA world.
Wow.
Dana's got it.
Really?
Wow.
Holy Shit.
Awesome.
Yeah,
but you can't have the desk though.
She's never going to go.
Really?
The why.
Why?
Because I'm the way.
I got a written.
He has a preexisting condition from the
motorcycle accident.
That's why he died because he takes a
blow to the head crafty Hollywood people
just know what a trick us.
The champion.
Do you ever.
You ever seen one of these things
before?
No.
This is the flashlight and what it is
is,
you know,
some masturbation technology device.
It's a to make jerking off better.
And for you,
and this is a collect the fluid there
and nobody's had sex touch it.
Is it collect the fluid in the bottom or
something?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
This is what I say.
The recycle will you released it?
Cracking of shame is how I describe it.
Go like that.
It just slid.
There's that fish in the bucket for this
is called fishing in the bucket.
Ladies and gentlemen,
for you watching on Itunes,
when you pull this flashlight out,
it's,
you know,
it's really soft,
fake vagina material and so when you
pull it out of this tube that looks like
a flashlight to see what looks like,
you know,
the,
the actual devices,
like it looks like a jellyfish sort of a
thing.
Wow.
What does that retail for?
Man?
I think it's like 60 bucks or something
like that,
but if you order through my website,
you get 15 percent off supposedly.
Supposedly we got to figure out how that
works to make sure,
but hopefully they're selling them
because the fucking things work.
Man.
You know everybody beats off.
Have I tried it just like today?
You haven't fucked it today.
Why would you try it?
You have the most beautiful life.
I know.
Wife getting crazy.
Just be realistic.
You have to be able to use your mind on
occasion.
You can't always fuck the same person or
someone else with your brain.
Flashlight does not talk.
Yeah.
It's not even that.
It's just like there's times where you
just.
It's like a maintenance thing.
You just gotta just gotTa beat off like
you don't want to have sex.
You don't have to time to get intimate.
You just like,
I need to get rid of some loads here.
Bam.
I can understand that.
You know when you're 18 in the shower in
the morning and brush your teeth Jack
off,
you don't understand that as a group,
but I don't understand that as a four
year old,
it just.
I think my hgh levels crashed.
Oh,
you got to start doing squat.
Going to get on them.
Dead lifts.
Son Handle Bells,
man.
Rick Schroeder just started doing
Jujitsu.
He is taking it now and you've been
taking it for like three days.
I've had four classes,
four days with Eddie.
Eddie Bravo.
He's a brick.
Shoulders learning has strangled pitch.
Have you had ringworm yet about that?
Listen,
I got some soap for you.
I'm going to give it to you before we
leave.
I wanted to have it out for the podcast,
but I forgot.
It's called defense soap that you can go
to.
Defense soap.com.
I have no affiliation with them.
The guy who owns it,
guy soccer was just this really cool guy
who made this great product and it's all
about keeping your skin healthy when you
do Jujitsu because when you do Jujitsu,
you're.
You're getting scratched and you're
rolling around.
There's a lot of abrasions all over your
body and if you don't wash with a good
healthy soap,
you can have like you getting infections
like ringworm and people don't tell you
about.
It's fucking really annoying.
You have to find out from other people
that do Jujitsu.
Like my friend already had a staph
infection on his knee and his knee had
swollen up.
We were playing pool and he's walking
around the pool table with this like
weird lump.
So I go,
what's going on man?
And he goes,
I got a spider bite.
And I go,
Oh shit,
let me see it.
So he pulls his pants up.
I go to,
that's a staph infection.
He thought it was a spider bite because
it was this big pus filled red mark.
It looked like he had gotten poisoned
with something you looked like.
There was like,
you know,
in Arizona.
So if I had noticed that it probably
could have got systemic and he would've
had to been in the hospital with ivy
intravenous antibiotics.
It's really,
really dangerous stuff.
What's the ringworm thing?
Is that to say no?
It's called.
No,
it's the same thing as athlete's foot.
It's really the same exact fungus.
It's just different parts of your body
and what ringworm is.
It's like it grows and it looks like a
ring,
you know,
when it starts to infect you,
like a big circle on your body and
that's how you crop circles.
Skin.
Yeah.
It's usually in circles.
So there's some knowledge at the gym
that you will need to.
I mean,
you don't want a sweaty guys on top of
you.
Kind of.
It was weird to get married at first.
It's weird as fuck man.
I know,
but I do it.
I think of it,
you know,
you don't even think of it really as a
dude.
You think of it as like a problem.
You think of it as like,
here's this,
you know,
there's this thing that's moving around
that I have to dissect,
you know,
I have to,
I have to dissect this guy,
I have to figure out how to lock them
down and figure out how to hold them in
place to figure out how to take his arm.
You've got what happened?
They're major volume.
Boom.
What'd you do that,
Brian?
Now my volume is gone.
Your body's gone.
Yeah.
You just fucked with something.
There you go.
That's all sensitive.
Well,
Mine's way loud.
I'm going to back off the mic.
Back off the mic.
So I'm loving the Jujitsu.
Yeah.
So Rick showed is out.
They're strangling bitches.
You got tapped by your own son now.
That's sad.
Really.
I coulda coulda gotten.
I could have gotten them all right.
I should have got them.
Then the next time it will tell you
something.
You have kids.
You can't let them tap you.
My other son,
he actually did get me.
Holden seems like a,
he's a big,
strong strapping fellow and he's just
starting to come into that.
So he's like really into it.
You know when I talked to him about your
Jitsu,
I was like,
dude,
you would love it.
He would love it.
And He needs that gym in Salt Lake.
Yeah.
He'll.
Jeremy Horn has a gym in Salt Lake.
He's going there for college,
right?
Yeah.
He just went there last week,
so he needs to go.
Well,
we'll get them.
We'll get them set up with Jeremy
Because Jeremy has got a killer.
Jim and Jeremy is like a really good
coach.
He's like,
one of the best guys you could ever
learn from.
Jeremy has always been like,
not,
not like a physically talented guy.
He's not a natural athlete,
not like super strong,
explosive.
Just really smart and really technical,
you know,
that's what he's always been like.
He's always been real clever on the
ground,
was just a great guy to learn from.
Those are the best guys to learn from.
The guys that are really strong
sometimes they're getting away with a
lot of it is just through athleticism
and they're not quite as technical as
the guys who are like naturally not that
strong.
It was the best guys to learn from.
Jeremy wanted one of the nicest guys in
the world.
Cool.
So hold them to love it.
He's going to be a killer.
It's going to come back.
There's gonna always a beach already
going to get you.
He's already a still.
What did he tap you with?
Um,
it was an arm.
It was an arm bar.
He got me in and um,
and luke got me on a regional not,
yeah,
but I,
I know my son and I could feel the
emotion,
like the boys and their dads have this
thing,
like especially when boys turns like 18,
19,
20,
they have to go through this thing where
they have to push their dad's away for
some reason.
It's part of the natural transition into
manhood and he was going,
he's going through that right now
because he's 18 and I could tell he
wanted to hurt me,
so I knew I needed to.
I knew I needed to just.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
And I said,
I tapped and he goes,
you can't tap.
I said,
no.
hold on.
I tapped.
He's like,
oh,
he just wanted to know how he didn't
want you to take a moment to tap.
Why would he not want you to tap if you
got you got you want to break your arm?
Well,
I don't think he wanted to break my arm,
but that's what happens when you don't
get the tap.
You just want to give me a little more
pain before I tapped out.
Wow.
That's fucking weird,
man.
I don't know how I'd handle that.
I'd have to beat the fuck out of him.
I think I might have to beat the fuck
out of him.
You're lucky you have girls.
Don't know how to deal with that.
I'm going to have to choke that dude.
I might have to be loaded.
We're going to figure some shit out
here.
No Damn.
Don't want to have to go through that.
Some fucking young buck running around
your house,
his chest puffed out and not listening
to you.
Oh,
well,
you know what?
You got to put the hooks in some other
way.
I got to get through to him.
Just squeeze them out.
You've got to be able to consistently
squeeze them out.
That's what's most important.
You can't just squeeze them out every
third time.
You've got to be able to squeeze them
out.
Every time you guys fuck out.
I'm going to get Eddie's Mondays and
Wednesdays for the next six months and
I'm gonna.
Learn some serious technique you can use
and he and I are going to.
We're gonna.
Go after it again.
Eventually we'll.
This is what you need to do.
All you need to do is be consistent,
be consistent.
That's the most important thing.
Be Consistent and spar a lot and get on
some sort of a strength program.
Get unlike lifting.
Kettle bells were the best because
they're really lightweight.
You can do it with like a 30 pound
Kettlebell,
35 pound kettle bell.
You get a tremendous workout.
I have one workout that I do.
It's just 1:35
pound kettle bell.
You called it the farmer strength.
You're using your,
your use your whole body and it just
forces you to use everything like
athletically as opposed to like like
just bench pressing,
isolating or twice as stuff doesn't
really enhance your ability to move
things.
It's like when you have like something
that you have to control and you have to
balance it.
Then you develop like a different kind
of a strength,
a strength that has like stability and
balance and strength and muscle.
Muscle groups using muscles adjust when
things are going wrong and when you're
getting tired,
you know that's what's really important.
You do that,
you'll choke the fuck out of that kid
that I'm talking about.
That little mother fucker shut up.
You got to be able to get them all the
time.
It's very important,
man.
You have to let him know that every time
you roll you're going to choke the fuck
out of them.
That's is a foregone conclusion.
There are certain dudes that you can you
just own.
Like when I first started doing Jujitsu
was this kid who was his purple belt who
really good and this dude owned me.
Every time we rolled he owned me.
It was a foregone conclusion I was going
to tap.
I sucked.
I was a white belt.
I didn't know what I was doing and he
was a really good purple belt.
He was strong as fuck and he used to
like to run through me.
That's what we would like to do.
Just fucking squash me as quick as he
could and it was like God damn.
But there was,
but you kept it as an order.
Yeah.
Well He,
you know,
he left and I went to another school,
the school that we were at close now.
But the important thing was I knew every
time I rolled with that guy,
unless I got way,
way,
way better,
get way better than I was.
That guy was gonna fuck me up every
time.
So there's like,
I didn't want to roll with them because
he owned me.
Know what I'm saying?
You got to own your kid.
Little mother fucker.
Just shut the fuck up.
That's what you gotta do.
Do a lot of it's psyching out too.
You might want to shave a Mohawk and
stuff like spitting on him and get some
potassium outside.
Someone that Mike Tyson face.
Tattoos.
Hold your gun sideways.
Fix Roads in town.
Mother fucker.
What they say?
God didn't make them an equal.
Smith and Wesson did well,
you know,
rick is a very unusual Hollywood guy.
You're not,
um,
you know,
everybody wants to say that like he's
not a Hollywood guy,
but you're not a Hollywood guy.
You're a dude who had a ranch out in
Colorado.
I know you love to hunt like you love a
lot of like manly shit.
Jujitsu is right up your alley.
Told him that.
I mean like I spear gun hunt.
He,
he got back from Africa and showed them
all this fucking shitty killed one on a
great safari with my son.
A fly airplane taking me.
We're going to go pig hunting.
We just have to figure out what was more
than pigs.
Actually we're going to do some.
We're going to do a buffalo.
I'm not doing anything.
I can't eat bison.
Bison,
you can,
but I'm just saying you guys kill Shit.
You can't eat.
He's going to eat everything that he
killed.
The only shit that I can't that would
kill that.
A kidney is like shit that I think like
coyotes to kill cats and shit.
I could kill a coyote.
You know,
like I've had cats.
I've had my,
you know,
my dog had killed by mountain lion in
Colorado.
What are we going hunting?
What do you have time?
We're going to figure it out right after
my book was supposed to be done with my
book by October 15th because November
it'll be cooler and we can hunt deer,
right?
We can hunt deer pig.
Dude.
I like the way deer taste.
I want to do it because I've been a
mediator my entire life and I've taken
no responsibility for my desire to
consume me.
I have not felt any remorse from pulling
the trigger and seeing an animal die.
I haven't made a connection,
a real connection between what you're
doing when you're eating meat and I
think as a person who thinks,
I think that's actually probably
important to try out an important,
you know,
hunting gathering was our past with some
men,
especially hunting,
gathering and like the further we get
away from that and that vibe of hunting
and gathering and providing and testing
ourselves like that.
I think the more out of touch we're
becoming with who we are leading a
great.
I think that is.
I think the world and technology
have evolved faster than people and I
think there's certain reward systems
that are set up in the human mind to
ensure that we're going to continue to
do certain things like that.
We're going to continue to want to fuck
that.
We're going to tend to continue to want
to hunt like you get like a response
from hunting.
I know I do from fishing.
I've never been hunting,
but I've been fishing and there's some
primal thing about pulling a big fish
out of the water that knowing that
you're going to eat this thing,
like you just went out into the wild
another world,
okay.
Floating around on the fucking ocean and
you pulled something out of that world
and now you're going to eat it.
It's going to give you life.
There's a little.
There's energy that's attached to that
like you feel good about it.
Well,
you know,
if the truth is of hunting and
gathering,
societies had succeeded.
They haven't succeeded because they were
replaced by mass farm production
societies plus changed everything.
We changed everything was the ability to
stay in one place.
People have like this sort of a nomadic
genetic connection.
There's a guy who lives in Alaska and
they chronicled him on.
You ever see VBS DOT TV?
You ever go to that website?
No.
Fucking phenomenal website.
This is.
There's a series called the vice squad
or the vice guide and they,
they do all kinds of weird shit like to
go to Africa and they go all over the
world.
North Korea,
but the one of the really coolest ones.
We went to this guy who lives by himself
and his wife in a cabin out in the
middle of nowhere in Alaska.
I mean he lives around bears and all he
does all day is hunt and bring food
back.
Catch fish and small fish.
Bring it back.
Yeah.
I don't know what he does for vegetables
cause he's like,
you know,
it's frozen up there.
I mean he's,
he's eating fucking Pine Collins.
I don't know what he's eating.
I mean I know he gets some supplies
dropped to him.
He never saw nine slash 11.
He hasn't even seen a photo of off the
grid.
These are guides.
They're holding off the grid.
There's guys,
they're doing that out there and he's
just,
but he's like so off the grid and he
says he's extremely happy and he,
and he's very articulate.
He's not like a crazy guy.
He's a very articulate guy who's been
doing this for a long time and he says
that as man gets further away from his
nature,
like this hunter gatherer nature you,
you,
you like lose your connection with the
earth,
your lose your happiness.
And he thought that that's the reason
why people,
you know,
like so many people are depressed and so
many people hate what they do.
Hunter and hunter and gathering like
this.
You're gonna love that.
There's like a visceral response,
like your genes get it.
Yeah.
And it clears your mind.
I mean,
when you're out trying to provide food
for yourself,
your family,
your friends,
and if that's all you're focused on,
then this,
all this other stuff and doesn't sort of
add up anymore,
you know,
it doesn't count.
Doesn't really matter.
And so hunting gathering,
I mean that's really where we came from,
but we're a dying breed,
hunting,
gathering people.
So do you think that that's one of the
reasons why suicide,
I mean it really does make sense,
right?
That that's one of the reasons why
people in society are so depressed is
that we are living a life like
technology and society has gotten far
past
where our genetics,
our genetics still require some acts for
us to feel good.
You know,
they have like there's a set in,
you know,
a reward system in place for doing
things like sex feels good so that you
make babies.
Food feels good so that you keep eating
and your survive.
All these reward systems are set up and
if you take a few of them out without
correcting the body,
like you're going to have like these
holes are going to have these problems
yet these voids over there and they're
filled with other things that are
probably not nearly as healthy or good.
I'm not a fascinating idea though that
were like,
it really is like you're looking at
evolution.
I mean you're looking at it,
you can tune back into it.
Like if you,
if you look at like the way it's set up,
it's set up to make sure that we do
certain things and if you take these
certain things away,
you,
the body gets fucked up.
Like it gets like W,
W we,
there's things were missing.
Like people who don't have sex.
I've always said this like it doesn't
matter how religious you are,
if you're not having sex,
you have sexual organs and you're not
using like do not.
You don't want to experience any
pleasure.
You don't wanna,
you don't wanna exchange love with
somebody like that.
You're going to break even.
That's not good.
That's not good at all.
No.
Sex is good because it was going to
grow.
The natural food is good.
I mean there's all these reward systems
that are set up.
It's just,
it's really fascinating that so few of
us are tuned into the hunter gatherer
thing that you are.
Yeah man.
I mean I grew up hunting like breathing
for me.
You know,
it's like it's just part of my life and
I bow hunt and I hunt with shotguns.
I hunt with a rifle as I hunt with blow
guns and spear guns.
I just hunt.
I just have to.
And you know,
one of the,
one of the Dranamo I think was the great
Indian warrior when he was finally
caught and put on the reservation,
they said to him,
so no drama.
What,
what are you going to do now?
There's no more hunting for you.
And he goes,
no,
we will hunt mice because we hunters and
we have to hunt and,
and that's just sort of,
it's in your blood that needs a hobby.
That shit's ridiculous in mice.
How about you play chess on,
settled down,
got to go hunt mice.
What?
Leave the fucking mice alone,
man.
Not necessarily always the kilo.
It's like the pursuit of something.
So do you feel like when you do it,
when you,
when you kill something and then get to
eat it,
do you feel like,
does,
is it triggers some sort of like a
primitive reward system that you feel
you feel it?
You know,
funny enough,
I actually don't like to eat a lot of
what I kill blacks,
which is.
Oh,
that's right.
We had this conversation and you're
like,
beef,
it's what's for dinner.
I like beef,
but none of my meat that I've ever
killed goes to waste.
I always give like my,
like I don't particularly like deer or
venison meat because it's so lean,
right?
I like fat.
I like,
I like um,
Ribeye steaks that are just full of
marbling.
So when I,
when I hunt,
I mean I do clean the meat and take care
of it and I was doing it to somebody,
a friend or family or somebody that
needs it.
But um,
it's,
it's really the pursuit and the capture
of the game that I get the,
the reward from the actual taking a bite
of it really.
You know what I mean?
It's.
See,
I,
I get that too.
But I think,
I think there's something in deer meat.
I think there's something in deer and
elk and this hear me out.
This sounds totally crazy,
but I think the things that are hard to
catch or better for you,
I think that if you've got a cow that's
just hanging around being a fat fuck and
you walk right up to him and shoot him
in the head,
I don't see how that's good for you.
I mean immediately it is good.
It tastes delicious and everything and I
eat steak like anybody,
but I think it's better to eat deer
because they're hard to catch when it
flees.
Be Really,
you know,
wouldn't you want to kill fleas?
All data for the same reasoning.
Oh my God.
No,
because you're not eating.
They're not animals that are praying you
hard.
You could squash them.
Tired.
I don't think I've ever seen a brian.
There's a thing called free split free
spray fleas.
You could fucking kill.
Billions of them was a stroke of a hand.
When you're ready to go hunting,
let me know.
Yeah,
we're.
We're going to go.
I,
I definitely want to go hunting for
another podcast when we get back.
When I lived in Colorado,
dear work everywhere.
It was crazy and all these fucking
liberals and hippies and in boulder,
no one is shooting any of these deer,
so they're so relaxed.
They're just standing there big fucking
10 point bucks just standing on the side
of the road looking at you and I stopped
the car and I'm like,
really?
I rolled down the window and I'm talking
to Diego.
Really?
He wasn't scared of me at all.
Just looking at me like,
what?
Bitch?
That's awesome.
The fucking huge man and they have elk.
When we went,
we looked at some property in evergreen
because I was convinced that that was my
move.
I needed to move to the mountains.
That was my.
I'm trying to get you in.
Well,
let's not talk about that on the
internet or a fucking psycho stalkers or
listening to pay going Wisconsin.
What's.
Anyway Evergreen.
Oh,
when we were looking at property in
evergreen,
there's a herd of elk that wandered.
They had photos.
They wandered down a certain path.
They walked through the fucking main
street in town every year and there's
like hundreds of them in their fucking
huge.
Like how bad ass is that like you're
standing there and as you're standing
there,
a herd of elk just walked through the
fucking town.
It's still not natural though.
I mean really.
I mean where I hunt elk and deer and
stuff,
man,
they're just wild.
So it's not natural.
It's not natural for not having fear,
man.
Oh yeah,
of course.
It's not natural.
It's not enough.
Yeah.
Well the problem is somehow or another,
this town was built on a path that they
always take the migration thing.
Yeah.
So I don't know.
I guess maybe there's also.
There's more fear of mountain lions than
there are people,
so they figure,
look,
at least we're around these crazy
assholes.
One of us is getting shot.
We're not all going to get picked apart
by a fucking flock of mountain lions
because that with mountain lions packs
packs
even.
They travel solo anyway.
No pack wouldn't have.
Maybe they'd be like,
oh,
they're spider.
They found in the Amazon you ever seen
that there's a spider.
They found the Amazon that attacks in
packs as the only spider in the world.
They attacked thousands of them at once,
so they make these gigantic nests.
Huge.
Spiderwebs were like,
like a deer could get stuck and when to
kill much larger things.
They kill rats and all kinds of crazy.
Cool.
It's the Amazon did the.
Amazon is.
There's A.
There's a BBC documentary about the
Amazon,
a two part series that I watched once.
I still have it on vhs.
I can't find it on DVD.
Like they don't have it.
It's fucking phenomenal.
They go into the Amazon.
Yeah,
and that's where they show these
spiders.
Like there's shit that's evolving in the
Amazon right now with the Amazon was is
it used to be like fields and then it
became a rainforest overnight.
Not overnight,
but really quickly.
So a lot of animals get stuck inside
this rain forest and they evolved like
there's an antelope,
it swims,
it's got little short legs and it swims
like up to 100 yards underwater and it
eats fish and it's a fucking antelope.
That's crazy how to do that because it
gets stuck there and the water and they
had to figure out another way to eat.
There's a fish that fucking climbs out
of the water,
walks till it finds the next pond and
jumps in.
That's pretty sick too.
Like so much crazy shit there.
It's all these animals that are adapting
to this,
you know,
just fucked up.
Changing the environment.
Bad Ass.
It's so awesome.
Oh,
it'll.
But the spider.
Anyway,
they found one spider.
They've never thought spiders did this
before,
but they found this one spider that acts
as a pack that's sick killer nor
spiderwebs,
and these little fucking mice get stuck
in them and shit and they just swarm on
foundations of spiders and you're like,
fuck.
He's just think what did.
That was me.
What if it's the middle of the night,
I'm going to take a piss and I stuck
with this
hallucination.
I don't fucking bikers out tracking you.
Did you see that photo I posted the
other day on twitter?
That spider my backyard.
I went and met back when it was this,
this big identify it.
It looked like the predators face.
That's what it looked like.
Where's the picture on my twitter?
Yeah.
Twitter.com/red
band could find health.
How many days ago?
Probably like a week ago,
a week ago.
I'll retweet or asking too much sun.
You're asking for research?
Read it tonight.
A spider scare the fuck out of me,
man.
I found five scorpions in my living room
once.
Five Scorpions.
Yeah.
There was like a nest.
They have scorpions out here.
Really?
Yes.
I've seen him many,
many,
many times,
and the little ones,
they're very dangerous.
They'll fuck you up,
man.
Trenchless,
right?
Rattlesnake was all the time.
Rattle snakes all the time.
We have rattlesnake fencing.
You know my,
my two pit bulls,
both of them had gotten bitten by
rattlesnakes when I had them.
Fucking rattle snakes are dangerous,
man.
They're all over the place.
Yeah.
When I lived in Calabasas,
I always found snakes all around the
ground,
just like eaten by other animals like
coyotes and step on one accidentally.
You gotta be real careful when you're
hiking.
We running.
I went running with the dogs and we run.
There's this hill that we run this dirt
road and when we were running down the
hill I was like,
oh,
here we are running over this log
and as I'm running over the log,
it's a fucking snake.
I realized as my feet were running over
it,
I was like,
oh my God,
he's a rattle snake is fat as my arms
giant.
The biggest rattlesnake I've ever seen.
I was like,
holy fuck.
I mean he was sat dude.
It was fat.
It was like a pitch.
It was like,
if that thing got you into like feel the
hot lava,
the fucking venom going into your
bloodstream immediately that Colt out in
Virginia that actually holds snakes and
um,
that's part of their religion.
If they don't get bit by the
rattlesnake,
then that means they're like pure and
stuff.
So there was this preacher guy who's in
prison right now because he wanted to
kill his wife.
So he stuffed her mailbox full of
rattlesnakes and she opened it up and
put her hand in and got bit in the jail
for attempted murder.
Damn,
that's some fire and brimstone type
shit.
That's type of shit like a preacher
would think.
Uncle Barry finch it,
fucking snakes.
Tom Story and Shit and a ride he killed
down by putting a moon.
She reached out.
Angela Lansbury somehow
involved with this whole thing.
Just something primal about doing that.
Getting some evil animal.
Do your dirty work.
Sentence somebody up that's.
That's like,
that's like way cooler than just
shooting somebody.
You know.
You said fucking rattlesnake Jackson.
When people eat,
it's always fucking husband and his
wife,
man.
God Damn.
I would like to know about the
percentage of people that kill
themselves or kill each other.
Rather.
What percentage are husband and wife or
the husband kills the wife or the wife
killed a husband?
Is it more than I like.
What is the percentage as far as like
people getting killed,
like how many of them are husband and
wife?
How many of them are just,
here's the guy that works at the post
office that I was fucking pissed me off,
so I shot him and how many of his
husband and wives I don't understand.
I don't think.
I don't think it would be as much as you
think.
I think domestic violence would be huge.
We've seen it goes all the way.
I
think we've all.
We've all seen for couples that are just
fucking violent to each other.
Right?
Yeah.
That's scary.
Shit.
That must be so scary for a cop.
You know?
They always say that those are the most
dangerous calls to take domestic
violence cases.
It doesn't seem so.
Like if you watched the show cops,
it doesn't seem like it's that big of a
deal to.
That was abused by his ex.
I can't go into details,
but she came out with a knife she met
with a few times.
He wasn't fucking her correctly.
No chip.
I'm fucking has ever come at me with a
knife.
He was.
You've got to keep them in check.
Have you got to have control?
Do not get involved in any sort of
relationship where you.
You're not the man.
If you're actually a man.
Don't get involved in
a relationship where you're not the man.
If you feel like,
well somehow with her I don't feel like
I'm the man and just.
I don't know what to do.
Get Out,
get out.
You're getting your souls getting stolen
from you in the night while you sleep.
You don't realize everybody's Alpha.
It's not.
It's don't.
Then whatever the role is,
make sure it's a harmonious one.
You know what I'm saying?
Don't let someone all of a sudden be
like the dominant one.
You figure you're not dominant anymore.
Like men who get in situations like that
where their wife gets the yelling and
the fathers,
the husbands always going,
okay,
okay.
That's not your name.
It's not healthy there.
There's just,
there's a girl out there somewhere.
It's probably nice and if they found
that girl instead of the one they went,
they found some chick who just likes to
look at the positive side of things and
she likes going to cool movies and
eating and fun places and she doesn't
require a lot,
you know,
that goes out there.
You don't have to listen to this.
Probably dead inside for that.
That was very good qualities,
you know,
that's why she's given up on life and
she's like up.
She's enjoying things.
Is that what it is when a chick isn't
crazy,
she's given up on.
Maybe it's just interesting.
Sit down and watch like a dead.
That's interesting.
So you think that any chick that's like,
no,
I don't really.
I didn't really think this out and just
throwing something on the table there.
I thought you were committed to this
man.
You.
You're not committed to this argument.
Rick doesn't even know what we're
talking about.
I kind of went over my head.
I took.
Rick showed up to his very first UFC
recently.
I was it.
It was good.
But the balance with you.
I want it to be inside where you guys
were.
I was like on the outside and I was like
too far.
I was looking up and I didn't have a
great view when you guys were on the
floor.
Like a floor seats are not my favorite.
It float my affairs one or two up.
I think you're right.
I think the first risers risers the best
spot because you're still close enough
to see the action.
You know,
but you're not.
Yeah,
you're not.
You're not looking up.
Plus when they go to the ground on the
other side of the cage,
if you're on the HD,
because I bought all the time on paper.
You like,
I get like the close ups.
I hear the sounds more.
I was more in the fight commentary here.
Yeah,
I didn't hear any commentary.
You can get these little.
They have these little radio things and
you uh,
they sell them a UFC fight link,
I believe it's called.
And you listened to it and you get to
listen to the commentary.
They broadcast it.
Unlike a wireless signal,
like a radio station on iphone APP for
that.
They should totally right.
Totally.
What the fuck,
Dana?
Dana gunders shit son.
It was cool though,
man.
We use a huge UFC fan.
Just wrote a movie about it.
So we'll see what happens.
But yeah,
I mean Rick Schroeder,
chuck,
Chuck Norris Talk to me.
Well,
it's like 15 years ago Chuck Norris
hugged me.
He's the greatest moment of my life.
She was like,
did he try to start some MMA league?
Well,
he did it.
He had a kickboxing league,
I think it was called the world combat
league.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure if that's the right name.
Fifteen years,
apologize from because I'm a huge
chuck Norris Fan and when he tried to
get me in on that way back in the
beginning like let's build a team in La.
That's exactly what he was doing.
He was doing kickboxing teams and they
tried to do that with the IFL.
IFL is the international fight league
and had some really good fighters,
but they tried to do that team thing
too.
They had tried to have them fighting
teams.
The only thing would be fun is if
they're all at once.
Well,
you know,
I thought it was.
I thought,
you know,
hey look,
say it's not the right way to go,
but at least it's something different
and people are talking about it like it
makes for a subject of debate.
Do you like this?
You're not like this,
you know,
it makes it a little novel.
But yeah,
it's not the way to do it.
Teams aren't the way to do it.
I would,
I,
you know,
when all those things were coming around
I was like,
what are you doing an individual sport
team?
Guess what they're doing is they're just
trying to get in on some unique way,
you know,
like everybody else is doing it this
way.
So we're gonna have teams,
the Denver douchebags and the fucking
the Montreal monsters,
you know,
folding chairs and do it.
Let's say it seemed very roller derby.
I was going to say that you went pro
wrestling on the same wavelength there.
It's a,
I don't know man.
It's,
it's interesting.
The only way to do is just do it.
Just have to stop trying to dress it up.
I,
I do like some strikeforce rules.
Strikeforce has put rules in when they
don't have elbows.
I don't know,
like a lot of people like elbows.
Fuck elbows cut people up man.
And I know you should just protect
yourself from that.
And you know,
and elbows can stop fights too.
They're very dangerous weapons but I
kinda like strikeforce held,
just use punches.
They don't elbow each other on the
ground.
I think it does.
I think it make,
it might make fighters' careers longer.
I mean people like it though and it's a
very effective technique.
Maybe they need some sort of a pat on
the elbow if that's possible,
you know,
that might not be a bad idea.
That doesn't cut it because it's such a
short movement when you're on top of a
gun and shoot your fucking short
distance to stop and so much power you
can generate and it's just bone on bone.
Just smashing your fucking face and
that's a.
that's a God damn dangerous technique
man.
Make it happen.
Like a sound like a dog toy though.
Every time they do it,
it's like a squishy toys.
Don't think there's any.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with elbows.
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
I wouldn't take them out either,
but I looked at the strikeforce rule and
I go,
maybe that's the way to go.
Sometimes.
Sometimes I'll look at it and go,
I like that.
That's around.
I liked,
you know what I do like,
I like that there's a comparison.
We can look at the strike force,
see,
see what happens with them.
With the punches on the ground,
like we've already done that with pride.
The old pride days,
they used to be able to do whatever they
wanted.
Man,
they could.
Soccer kick dudes while their heads were
on the ground and stomp on them,
they don't think they allowed headbutts
and they don't think they allow growing,
growing kicks.
I don't.
I don't think the allowed fish hooking
or any of this stuff that's always
illegal.
They didn't allow it,
but they added the stomps and the soccer
kicks and the knees to the head to a
downed opponent and it's all really
fucking violent,
dangerous shit.
You know when you see a guy get soccer
kicked in the head,
that's when you know,
you're like,
whoa,
like shit,
this is,
this is not fucking playing around.
This is a real fight.
Like that guy just soccer kicked that
guy in the face when he's down.
It's not the best thing to have an MMA,
but pocket adds this crazy element to
it.
You know when a guy goes down,
the other guys trying to stomp them,
like literally like,
whoa.
Vandelay silva knocked out.
I think it was tomorrow.
No,
it wasn't Tamora.
Damn.
I forgot who it was.
Yuki Kondo.
Yes,
I believe it was.
He knocked him out and then he started
stomping his fucking head while he was
down,
but then early UFC is like biting and
stuff.
Maybe it wasn't usually condo.
I should.
I should find out exactly who it was
with vandelay do that before I said it,
but whoever it was,
he was holding onto the ropes with one
hand than kicking the guy in the face
stomping on his head while he was down.
It was so violent.
I was like,
fuck.
Like that.
Took it to another level.
That's the rep's fault though.
For now it's illegal.
It's illegal.
In Japan it's legal will pan and pride.
It was legal.
I think you can still do it.
I know you can definitely still kick or
nea down.
Deponent,
I think you could soccer kick him still
to and you can stomp them still to I
think.
I think dream the way they do.
I mean there's.
There's different organizations,
like one of the things that the UFC has
always been pushing for is a unified
system of rules.
So the rules we use,
everybody uses so that we all practice
the same sport.
That makes complete sense.
Totally complete sense.
It's totally the right way to go.
But Japan was either fuck don't like
five minute,
10 minute round and they have crazy shit
with her coming in and they'll take your
money away if they don't think you're
fighting hard enough.
Really?
Yeah Dude,
they get crazy laws over there.
So like say if a and sometimes man dudes
are just taking a fucking breather,
like it's a war,
you know?
Or they neutralize each other.
They can't,
nobody can get anything done.
And I go stop,
stop.
And they pull out a yellow card.
And what a yellow card is is they take
10 percent of your fucking purse.
So if you're getting paid 100 grand,
you just lost $10,000
because some fucking douchebag referee
decided you needed a yellow card because
you're not fighting hard enough.
At least it's just that in Japan a
yellow card can mean a lot of things.
It could be get the use and the women
that cut your finger off,
it could mean that's a p card.
That's the craziest thing ever.
The Yakuza where they chopped his
fingers off,
fuck up.
You do something wrong.
You have to cut your finger off.
That's your.
That's your punishment.
Yeah.
That's one of the pumps because you hear
about the Saudis trying to paralyze some
guy.
Did they go through with it?
You know,
I don't know if they've gone through
with it.
I know they're inquiring on whether or
not it can be done.
One hospital said they wouldn't be
doing.
If you don't know the story,
there's a.
A guy hit a guy with a shovel,
so when he hit him with,
I don't know any details,
he assaulted this guy in some way and
and paralyzed him and under Islamic law
and you know,
I foreign high.
They literally want to impose the exact
same injury to this guy and do it in a
hospital.
One hospital.
It's like you can't paralyze somebody.
Like we can't just do that in another
hospital said it was possible,
but they did not have the conditions
available.
They would have to go to a much larger
hospital,
so they probably went to some fucking
goat and donkey infested the hospital
with chickens running through the
fucking bobby.
He's like,
would you be willing to paralyze
someone?
And they're like,
well maybe we can do it here though.
There's a guy in south central,
they'll do it for $100.
Would you guys.
Do you guys agree with that though?
Eye for an eye judgments,
man.
You know what?
I think there's just a certain amount of
cruelty to that.
It's not necessary.
I think if you want to show people that
it's wrong,
killed a guy.
That's what I think.
I say death penalty is a good thing,
but you know what I mean?
You have to know the circumstances.
Who knows?
Maybe the other guy is a dickhead.
Maybe the other guy threw a rock first
and then he hit him with a shovel and
paralyzed him.
We don't have enough information.
Maybe that guy was fucking tormenting
him and he wouldn't leave his kids
alone.
It was an asshole kicked his dog and you
know,
it was building up over 10 fucking years
and finally homeboy had enough and he
just did what he supposed to have done a
long time ago.
Crack that motherfucker over the head
with a shovel.
But unfortunately his little faggot ass
has to go and get paralyzed and now my
mans in the pokey and they're talking
about paralyzing him too.
Meanwhile all he was dealing with just
trying to hold his ground,
just trying to get by in this world,
you know,
just trying to.
They should have the three strike rule.
Like the first time you do something
really,
really bad,
they cut it.
They take away your hearing.
Then the second time they take away your
eyesight.
Third time to chop off your tongue.
Dude,
you might've just invented that.
And there's people in Iran right now,
right?
I did.
Before the ideas,
get that back,
come up solutions.
It's hilarious.
It's cheaper.
Codeine goes,
I have a car account.
Their retail,
me not,
dude,
I don't know what action we were there
at the end.
We went Japanese and we started off.
We have the worst fake Iranian accent
ever.
I'm an insult to any impersonator out
there.
Joe,
what can I tell you,
man?
Without telling me.
What do you want to know about back in
the day?
Dude,
what I want to know.
Everything we know.
I've,
I've been friends with rick for a few
years.
Four or five years.
Gotten more friendly lately since he got
back from Spain?
Yes,
please.
Yeah,
just really changed and I became a
pussy.
Okay.
Hold on.
Like all the other posts out there in
the world?
No,
I'm,
you know,
for sure.
I don't think you can understand what
it's like to have children until you
have children and you know,
Louis Ck said something once about kids
I thought was really interesting.
He said just let it change you.
And uh,
I had already like kind of let it change
me before I heard that.
But I was like,
wow,
that's like the best way to describe it.
Let it change you,
you know?
And when you have kids,
that's.
That really is what happens like you,
you,
all of a sudden,
first of all,
the immediately when I started doing is
looking at people as babies.
I looked at everybody.
I used to just see a guy who's 30 and I
was like,
Oh,
here's a guy.
Hey Buddy,
what's up?
Nothing.
You know,
normal.
But now you said like the inner child it
now I didn't see the inner child to see
how he developed to be that guy.
You have much more compassion for
people,
you know.
That's cool.
I try to.
I try to keep as much compassion as
possible while still avoiding Douche
bags.
That's my ethic.
But there's a certain point in time
where sometimes you have to go,
dude,
shut the fuck up.
Please leave me alone.
I know you were a baby once.
No one point in time you were an
innocent little child and somebody
fucked your programming up.
I understand this.
You got to let me go.
I got shit.
I gotta do you know it's right,
right.
I get it.
But yeah,
you have changed at time.
So I think everybody does.
If you don't change when you have kids,
you were full,
you'd be crazy to you.
The worst thing in the world that you
could ever feel is that you didn't do
your best when you were raising a kid.
That's got to be the worst thing because
I think your childhood was fucking
completely bizarre.
I mean,
my childhood was bizarre on paper,
but it wasn't bizarre in front of the
whole world,
you know?
And you became a fucking superstar when
you were a little kid.
You're 40 now,
right?
Just.
Okay.
I'm 43.
So when I saw the champ,
I think I was seven.
What were you like for?
No,
no,
I was seven.
So you were 10 and the champ.
Really?
Okay.
My,
my,
my time rotten.
Either way.
Either way,
whatever I was seven or 10.
I was fucking crying like a baby.
And you were even younger than me then.
So when I was a little kid,
when I was like going through life,
trying to figure out,
you know,
what my parents were breaking,
I'm going to try and figure out like,
fuck,
what is life all about?
You were fucking famous in front of the
world,
like I couldn't imagine that point in my
life being famous.
That must've been so strange to develop
in that.
But you're so normal.
Well,
here's the thing that's I think
interesting about like growing up famous
because I became famous when I was
seven,
so I don't have any memory of life
before fame.
Wow.
So when that happens and you're forming
and you're getting programmed and you're
getting created as a child,
right?
That's where it becomes normal for you.
And so I don't have any frame of
reference like I wasn't 30 and all of a
sudden Bam became famous and I had 30
years of history of normal life.
So fame is normal for me.
So because it's normal,
that means kind of.
It's not special because what's normal
is normal.
Right.
So that's kind of,
I think at different unique thing about
being a child actor.
Like I wasn't.
I started bag barrymore last night.
I went to never heard anybody put it
that way before I went to her premier
last night and she,
she's kind of done the same thing and
her new movie and uh,
gave her a big hug and kiss.
I haven't seen her in 20 years.
Do you grab her ass and not just cheat
girl though?
Get rid.
Get rid of a case.
I've known her since I felt good.
I felt good.
She was eight as drew barrymore dance.
I'm Tom Green.
That God that you could get that poor
kid.
She picks the weirdest guys.
It's great.
I love Tom Green.
Yeah,
I'll do his show.
No,
I didn't.
He doesn't show like Canadian far more
sophisticated.
Yeah,
he's Canadian,
but you can trust him.
I trust him.
He's one of the good news to see the
show where he took animals into his
parents house at a zoo.
He fucked a moose on the side of the
road.
He's a savage.
Yeah.
He's.
He's fucking awesome.
I love that dude.
He's a really cool guy too.
His.
He's got a,
like a show that he's been doing out of
his house.
He turned his living room into a studio
where
he like broadcast a live talk show from
his living room and it's super popular.
It's really good.
It's interesting.
You get to see him changing and trying
different things.
When I got to him,
he was into the secret who's like,
really?
He's like head of a copy of it right
there.
I mean,
I don't even know if he was telling the
truth.
I believe he was,
but it seemed like almost it was like,
it was like it was trolling you was just
fucking around pretending to be into the
secret thing.
But um,
so drew the same thing.
It's been a few of us that have gone
through that,
like not many very,
very few.
I could count on a hand the percentage
of people who go through that and get
Lindsay Lohan or like,
it's like 95.
Right.
More more than it's gotta be.
What do you think was the difference
with you or what's the difference?
You know,
I quit the partying thing when I was
young and I didn't continue it.
Like I think some people do and you
know,
I had my few wildly years between 16 and
20,
but you know,
I always kept my kind of stuff quiet and
I kind of kept it under the radar and it
wasn't really public about it.
And then I met [inaudible].
There was no TMZ,
there's no internet,
no one in the sun.
And keep it on the dl here making it
rain.
Do you ever wonder,
like when I was 20 I met Andrea and that
just kind of changed my life because I
was,
I was a data at 22.
Oh.
So that's a big part of it.
Too.
Responsibility.
Very early on.
How did you used to hang out with all
those people back in the data?
Like Gary Coleman and all those guys.
Like I like where you're like hanging
with punky brewster and stuff.
Yeah,
I knew everybody there.
I mean the different strokes kids.
We're filming next door.
The facts of life.
Girls were across the other studio
stage.
Did you guys met each other?
Who's the boss?
Kids.
Did you guys into?
You must've,
right?
Yeah.
It's small wonder ustream.
USTREAM crowd knows what's up,
so yeah,
there was some drama going on on,
on set.
You know what I mean?
There was.
I told you a little bit about the top
bridges todd bridges I had.
We had todd bridges on fear factor and
he had a chip on his shoulder.
I mean,
not,
not.
I mean it wasn't a bad guy,
but had this thought that everybody was
out to fuck them.
Everybody,
like we were fucking them over like we
didn't want them to win.
Oh,
I see.
What's up.
You don't want me to when I was like to,
but the guy or the guy beat yet.
What am I going to say?
Come on man.
It's ridiculous.
But he's got a new book out,
so like God bless him.
I hope he sells it and stuff,
but.
Well he just,
you know,
he didn't.
My point is he did not get through it
the way you got through.
He was chasing me around with a pistol
full of urine.
Wow.
Water pistol.
He was,
he was.
Yeah.
I mean,
he was pissing a water pistol and then
just say,
okay,
I'm going to score it.
The rest of us will be thrown water cups
at each other and crap,
and he took it to the next level and
just started squirting it was urine.
Ran Him over with your training.
He was big and he was older.
We were all scared of todd.
How old was he?
And we were all like 13,
14 and he's all like 18.
19.
Oh my God.
He was 18 and 19.
He was pissing in little kids faces.
Yeah.
Kelly was the originator of that.
He had a porsche.
Right.
And so he was racing around the studio
and stuff and I remember I was 16.
I had just gotten my nine,
44 turbo and he's like,
let me take it for a drive.
And I'm like,
oh,
okay.
So I gave him the car keys and he's
like,
this thing is broken and right.
He just abused my car.
He brought it back with bald spots on
the time.
Wow.
And you let them do that to todd
bridges?
Yeah.
Well,
todd bridges,
he wasn't a bad dude though.
He's just so.
He's just a fucking baby.
That got stuck into a weird situation.
They just didn't develop that.
Right.
Dana?
Plato became a drug addict,
right?
Yeah,
she died in Vegas.
That's the place to die.
You're gonna die with other drug
addicts.
The disease.
Segal finds its flock.
Can I place it?
This quote that I was talking about
earlier?
Oh yeah.
This is silver spoons.
Yeah,
it was from.
I love.
I love silver spoons,
but this is one of my favorite quotes
and it's so weird to listen to right
now.
Listen,
listen,
listen to this.
That's fine.
What's like the recording?
This is crazy.
See computers,
a teacher someday.
People that do their computers are
shopping Sunday almost every computer.
We need special stories that books with
the state.
That was Arnold Jackson trying to talk.
Steal money lets me and Gary Coleman.
So listen to what you were saying man.
You were saying that like was it 1983 or
82?
What'd you do?
Man?
You got done?
You shut the power off.
I'm back.
Anyway.
Um,
so how,
how did they fucking predict that so?
Well,
it's kind of like,
did you guys get like computers?
I'm like Steve Jobs or stuff that they
like because of that whole show was
about computers.
Did you have like the inside word where
you.
Are you a prophet?
No,
I don't know.
You're a mormon.
You will be a profit deal.
Games been on set and stuff.
So I don't know about the computer thing
I can as a kid.
How crazy.
You were like you were like kid porn for
us.
You were like duty is a pac man machine.
He has a train.
You've got every single toy in the rural
and it was like we idolized you as kids
at our age group.
I'm 36 so it's like duct phone.
Yeah.
It had like a remote control for my year
with Mr Aaron Gray Man.
If there was a tmz back during gray,
what would,
what would they have caught you doing?
What would them coming you?
We'll be popping bottles,
hanging out the hotel.
Roosevelt with Alfonzo and Corey Haim
and Corey Feldman back in 1986.
80 seven.
Roosevelt.
Wasn't nice really.
It was a dive.
What was back then,
was it dive club Hollywood,
you remember called Hotel Roosevelt.
Super Cool.
I remember,
I remember hearing about club Hollywood,
you know,
back in the day,
like teen bop magazine Hollywood.
That was so weird,
man.
Corey Haim's dead.
Nobody saw that coming.
So.
Oh,
how weird is it that there's these kids
that grew up with you that didn't make
it through the net?
How weird is that to watch?
Um,
yeah.
It's,
I feel really bad for the kid like Corey
Haim that you knew when he was a little
kid.
Yeah.
He was so good to,
you know,
dude,
when he was little,
when the two of them weren't.
What was that fucking vampire movie?
Lost Boys.
Just boys.
They were good in those movies that he
was a good actor.
Yeah.
So you must have hung out with Michael
Jackson.
And what did it taste like?
You remember that kid?
Yeah.
I mean he was a real talent that was
crazy dying on sunset strip.
You know?
What about Michael Jackson used to hang
out with them?
Michael Jackson visited the set of
silver spoons.
Wow.
What was that like?
He was friends with Alfonzo who was my
buddy on silver spoons,
you know,
Fonzo who was on the fresh prince right
after source.
And what's his last name again?
Roberto Rivera Alfonzo.
So yeah,
he came to visit one day,
Michael Jackson and I'm hanging out with
Alfonzo.
Cause a fun commercial.
That was when he was the biggest star on
the planet ever.
Huge.
Yeah,
huge.
It was um,
that was going to tell about my book and
that was like through made me very
uncomfortable.
I don't really kiss on the lips.
Was bullshitting.
He's Michael Jackson estate lawyers
down.
Do you think he fucked kids?
You must've heard stories.
I don't know about anal,
but I think it might be.
Might have been some inappropriate stuff
if I had to guess,
like some hand jobs and I was like,
don't go over it.
Really.
I heard so many rumors about Michael
Jackson and why he's,
he's,
you know,
why he was the way he was.
But you were actually there.
What was he like?
Like I wanted to.
I mean,
I'll funds that,
went to the universal amphitheater,
wants to see him play,
and we went into his,
this was Billie Jean Times.
Yeah,
this is the time.
So she of complaint it,
thrillers,
planet starting the universe.
And so,
um,
we're hanging out in his trailer and um,
you know,
just hanging out really nice quiet,
shy guy.
And so I'm like 16,
17.
I said,
Michael,
what's you,
how did you make it from a kid actor to
an adult like this,
you know,
how did you survive?
Because I was kind of in the middle of
transitioning from a kid to an adult.
And he said,
you know what the trick was being
inspired ricky,
because I had to be inspired to keep it
up.
And I had to find stuff that I wanted to
work on and wanting to do.
And you know,
I,
I kind of took that advice to heart,
you know,
but no,
nothing ever inappropriate.
And he started kissing her nipples.
Nothing inappropriate happened with me
or that I know of.
He's such an odd.
He was such an odd guy,
just even the way his voice was.
And it was very strange.
It that's a man's voice,
just,
it's such an odd character,
you know,
but never been a guy who was so much to
get out.
I mean,
we talked about it last week and the
podcast,
like how crazy it was watching them
dance.
It's like nobody ever did anything like
that before.
Like even though this Elvis did,
but he did in a different way.
He was,
he had a.
It was a weird thing of Sammy Davis.
He took some from Brown,
Jim Brown,
James Brown,
James Brown.
We were talking about.
We would watch that on the podcast a
couple weeks ago.
The opening and Zaire.
James Brown was like manly the way
James.
I was like,
it was more like a Michael Jackson did
it.
It's more like gliding,
almost like alien type character.
It's moving around in perfect
synchronicity.
It was like the more of a,
more of a perfection to Michael
Jackson's movements.
Whereas like James Brown was more of
like raw sexuality that had the jet
Michael Jackson Jacket.
Do you remember it?
Totally generic one though.
I can enter my family couldn't afford
the real ones.
We got the generic one at this store
called Gold Circle.
It looked exactly the same,
but there was some kind of tag the real
one had and immediately everyone's like
fake people had fake things.
Fake members only.
I had a fake izod wasn't a crocodiles
like something else or a flux.
Lizards have never crocodile.
That's a weird thing with kids,
right?
Yeah.
The need for brand names.
Shit on Bros.
Spelled with a q.
What doeS that member?
This umbro shirts,
shorts.
He used to be real popular back in the
day.
Same thing.
They have generic brands.
I was like columbo or this want to talk
about popularity.
You have young kids.
Yeah.
How the fuck is that?
Sagging things still in.
How the fuck are people sagging their
pants still?
It's just like wearing pajamas pants to
half their ass.
Half their ass and then they're pulling
the belt on their pants.
Stay on it to show you like how good
they cleaned.
Seen tensions.
Now is back.
No dude,
I'm telling you.
Whatever is back tight jeans style.
What people are doing.
Those guys are still sagging everywhere.
Everywhere I go,
I'm meeting kids in the crotch of their
pants is by their knee and they can't
even fucking walk while you're flying in
general and it's going to end.
I don't think it's going to end.
That's what I'm telling you.
This has been around since I was in high
school and it was one of those things
where I thought,
okay,
this is bell bottom jeans,
this is fucking wearing a visor.
This shit is gonna.
Go away.
You know?
It was back like,
I don't want people fucking sagged ha.
I remember parachute pants.
It wasn't as many,
but it was still.
It came from prison.
The whole thing comes from when you go
to prison,
they take away your belt so you can't
choke yourself.
Death.
We don't have a weapon either.
So your pants are sagging off and you're
losing weight because you're not eating
as much as you were when you first got
it,
you know?
Yeah.
Probably.
Or you're eating more debt yet.
Getting that hades food anyway.
That would suck.
Being in prison.
What story?
What could be worse than getting your
freedom taken?
Oh no,
I think I'd rather be dead.
What's amazing is the,
all the different shit they can put you
in position for,
you know,
so the webster story,
so,
so I'm,
you know,
at one of these network junkets where
you go to promote your show and stuff
and all
the other actors and cast or they're
from the shows and this little man black
kid this tall was just cute as can be
man.
And just like I put them on my knee and
I started just playing with them and
bounce them around and he was giggling
and laughing and having a good time.
And then like,
you know,
I liked kids,
I've always liked kids.
So I laid the kid back and I blew like
login is zuckerberg.
Dell calls it bloom a couple of shirts
and he's like giggling like a little,
like a little four year old.
Right?
And I put them away and the below and go
ahead.
Now I'm done playing with you and
somebody comes over and says,
you know,
he's 16.
He didn't say anything.
He just laughed.
Oh my god,
that's the best story ever.
Oh my holy shit.
You fucking gave 16 year old webster on
a one.
On a one to 10.
What was the embarrassment level when
you found out he was your age?
I feel really.
What did you think?
I feel bad and I felt gross.
Gross.
You apologize to him.
No,
I call them my again,
ever.
You didn't even apologize.
Where's he really laughing then when you
did or was he.
You had to go back and do it again
today.
Would you apologize,
but I apologize.
I wasn't too bad.
Too bad.
There's no cell phone cameras back then.
Can you imagine somebody filming that?
He pumped.
Melissa gilbert was teaching me to
juggle that data and looked at a joel.
How.
Okay.
Humbled.
I thought he was like four or five.
I thought it was just like a little kid,
you know,
if we can get them,
can we film and recreate it?
Reenact it.
What exactly happened with the awesome.
I met him once at the comedy store.
He's a very nice guy.
Really nice guy.
He was very friendly.
A nice guy.
Yeah,
he was fine.
He was.
You guys tasted like sugar,
tastes like.
Do you remember what he tasted like,
honey?
It's old spice.
Only feel bad.
When I found out how old,
it was like,
whoa,
baby.
A fucking babies got razor stubble and a
tattoo.
Baby's got a hard on.
What the fuck?
Michael jackson's glove on his ass.
Could you imagine?
How do you know him?
Well,
do you know when the first time he got
laid off?
Gary coleman story was fascinating.
He was like 40 virgin virgin bridges.
It wasn't it.
He should have taken that money if I was
his advisor.
Okay.
And I would say,
I would say,
let's,
uh,
let's get rid of the showbiz
aspirations.
Let's just let
it go.
We've got about 50 grand in the bank.
I think it's time to move to Thailand.
Things.
Time to go.
Thailand,
Thailand.
You're a celebrity.
Okay.
You still got 50 grand will go a long
goddamn way.
He can get yourself a nice girl.
Settle down in the jungle.
Lauren's.
Learn some moitai.
Go fishing.
Okay.
America is not for you.
So you're going to get some fucking.
The chick that did marry him,
did you ever see the chicken married?
She took pictures on his deathbed when
she was looking at the rough,
like just get like a self portrait and
he's fucked up with pipes.
Tubes coming out.
Oh,
it's beyond grows.
It's,
it's one of the darkest pictures.
I've seen a lot that I think I've ever
seen on the internet.
It's true.
One of the darkest pictures because it's
just like the.
There's such a lack of love and respect
and there's a lack of remorse and she's
not sad that he's dying or if she is,
it's not that sad and terrible.
I don't know.
I mean,
who knows how he treated her,
you know,
of course,
treated like shit.
He probably yelled at everybody,
but you know,
the guy's like,
yeah,
he was born fucked up.
Could you imagine just going through
life going,
there's no way to fix this.
And he was so talented though.
Wasn't active when he was a kid.
I mean,
he was amazing.
If you go back and rewatch,
what do you do if you associate guy like
that?
That's what the hard part is.
How do you transition from being,
you know,
I mean it's really,
I guess if you could write your own
shit,
if you could write your own thing that's
really good about a guy who was in your
situation,
you know,
then you could come up with some sort of
a show as an adult,
you know,
it's possible,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
but you got to adapt and morph and
change and grow with the times.
And that's,
I think what happens to a lot of child
actresses,
they kind of don't.
They also,
you know,
they're used to being treated a certain
way and getting certain big paydays and
certain big checks and when they,
when it's time to humble yourself and
sort of start working again for less or
you know,
start doing things that you may not
really like,
they were.
Their egos are too big,
so you got to stay humble.
I think that's the one of the biggest
heart and Aaron Aaron Gray helps.
Doesn't see Aaron Graves.
How hard is it useful?
Is it to stay humble?
That is the most hard thing,
right?
It's the most confusing thing is when
you know that you're just a normal
person,
but everybody treats you like you're
special because you're a star,
like when you're on a set,
if you're on a set like a sitcom,
it's so easy to lose your head because
everyone's kissing your ass and all the
network people are all walking on
eggshells around you.
They want to be really friendly with you
and everybody wants to be nice to you.
Everyone's got a big smile.
The show's doing well.
Everyone kisses your ass.
It's like you live in some weird and
then you had an accountant and you got
an a lawyer that kisses.
You're asking a publicist,
the kisses,
your asset manager and all these people
that you're employing that kind of
kissing your ass.
That's why it's important just to have
real people.
It's very hard to pull off.
For some people,
it's very hard to get yourself out of
that spiral of confusion,
your identity confusion,
like,
who the fuck am I?
Yeah,
but my friends were always outside of
hollywood.
That was important.
That's the most.
My friends are always just guys that
were farmers or ranchers or hunters,
or if you just go knock on their door,
I'm schroeder and I'm for somebody.
Fellows.
Hunters play my video games.
Let me be your friend.
Fogger.
I've got one in my house.
What's up son?
You pat it dragon's layer dragons on
set.
You did dragon's layer was the one where
it was a cartoon.
He did the right thing.
What was the lead character's name?
I love that.
That game would just suck him.
I remember I go to western,
I was a kid and I bring like $40 a
quarters and just sit there and play all
night until I was sweating and mock
three.
Remember that one Where it was like real
jet footage where it looks like you're a
plane and you were like shooting down
things.
I remember a lot of those.
mock three.
Really remember dragon's lair.
That was the best call of duty's my game
though.
Totally fucking so much,
dude.
When you go through the airport at that
one,
you know you just start hmong people at
the airport.
Have you played a multiplayer?
Oh dude,
you goT to do it online.
No,
I've done the campaign,
but I like to play online against the
kid.
I get a d.
You get addicted.
Get addicted.
Bad.
Do you play with the xbox or the
playstation?
I have both,
but is that what you do with console to
console?
Xbox,
but I usually.
I like pc games with keyboard and mouse.
You have much more control.
I like first person shooters.
I like playing like duals and quake.
Low of call of duty.
Fucking freak out.
Right?
He just remembers quake,
quake,
the call of duty.
No,
listen,
I have a show in his age.
Diction.
I have a real addiction to gamers know
it's quake,
quake online stills the best game.
Literally 40,
40 is tHe cutoff.
Literally I found out for what?
For like the video game junkies.
Oh,
that's nonsense.
Listen man,
the fuck you want.
You're not.
No one is making the rules.
No ones making the rules.
do what you enjoy doing.
All right.
This is all nonsense.
You're going to be dead some day.
Do what you like now.
Don't do what you'd like because you
want to pretend to like it because other
people think you're sophisticated.
Then you're gonna.
Want to go on a fucking musicals and
shit?
You know what you like?
Video games are way better than
musicals.
Okay?
Video games are fun as fuck.
It doesn't matter if you're 80 years
old.
If you fucking get some stereo
headphones,
get a good fast cable internet line and
get online and play some quake.
Holy shit dude.
People coming out of left side,
the right side of rockets flying at you
and you fucking mellon people down with
a lightning gun.
Craig,
I didn't.
Never even never heard acquaintance.
You're showing your age.
Son sheds ridiculous shit.
Joe.
I know you,
but if you played this game play on the
computer,
you can play it on the computer.
Imagine that times 50 billion,
but what is it?
Okay.
Well,
tell me why it's so great.
Graphics.
One incredible low your mind and the
weapons the weapons will blow your mind
playing with like 50 other people at
once will blow your mind and you can
hide in trees and be a sniper if you
weren't scared,
scared you should.
You Should take a week off.
I had a friend that he lost his mind
once.
He was an actor.
he lost his mind wants and this dude had
never been in the military and he called
me up.
He goes,
if everything doesn't fucking pick up,
I'm thinking I'm just going to go to a
rock and start killing people.
Wow.
I'm like,
whaT?
I go,
what are you talking about?
And he's like,
you know what man?
Fuck it.
At this point in my,
I'm ready to join the mercenaries.
Like,
okay,
I can't talk to anymore.
I stopped talking to him last time.
We talked to him like,
I wonder if this dude is just been
playing a lot of video games and it's
like.
And he's like,
you know,
fuck it.
I'll just get a good fucking get fragged
go over there and end it all.
I wonder,
you know,
what is it about,
you mean do you think people get
desensitized playing video games?
So the idea of real war for sure.
That makes sense for sure,
but I don't think I'm making sense.
Has like totally fake like movement,
like the,
the,
the physics of the game are not human
physics like you to jump further than
you could ever really just about jumping
john.
You strafe jump and you can really go
jumping sideways and you could walk it
jump.
EspecIally playing rocket arena.
This is.
The physics are just crazy wild nobody.
Physics.
I think your games are like little
little.
Yeah.
I'm not interested in that,
but I want to Catch a dude in midair
with a rail gun.
Now I'm talking about makes it jump.
I boom.
I bet you if we get in here and we hook
up our computers together,
I bet in within an hour fucking like,
it's crazy man.
I love you.
Shoot somebody through your head,
man.
Like the whole wall behind you.
It's splattered with blood and in the
game and the wall will start to have to
pull out my flashlight right then and
there.
If someone's fucking head explodes
behind them,
I might just,
I might get a viking horn fucking my
fleshlight and blowing my horn.
Dan's head exploded splattered against
the wall.
There's got to be satisfying.
If you're a bad guy and you shoot
somebody in their brain splattered
against the wall,
that's got to be upset.
I mean,
you know,
it's not.
There's no positive carmen murder,
but You know,
you get an a for artistic effect.
have you been to um,
I went to the New York and was doing
nytd blue and I went to do research with
some cops there on how to be a cop and
they took me to the morgue.
Grew up into a morgue.
You to have an intense.
They had a wall like the size of that
wall with polaroids over probably the
last 30 years,
the most gruesome killings you've ever
seen.
And I remember one,
jill,
the guY had put a double barrel shotgun
in his mouth and pulled the trigger and
his head had split perfectly down the
middle and there was one on each
shoulder.
His head was split and laying on the
show,
one on each shoulder,
like perfect.
And it was unbelievable.
But anyway,
um,
yeah,
it's,
he should've tweeted dose.
You need a twitter.
Unbelievable photographs.
God damn there was this one.
This girl.
We wanted this one crime scene.
The guys didn't want to pay this
prostitute tossed off the roof,
bounced off the air conditioners 13
floors down.
Oh god.
Crazy stuff.
Like real stuff.
Frigidaire.
They didn't want her on prostitutes.
So they threw her out the window.
Oh my god.
13.
Yeah,
You can see the blood smears like it
double offense against humanity.
I mean,
think about how empty you have to be to.
First of all,
you're not just getting this prostitute
that you don't give a fuck about,
but you're going to kill her rather than
pay her.
It's crazy.
You've taken someone's child and you
fucked her and then you decide you
don't.
You don't need your words,
your words are worth less than nothing
worth less than nothing.
Row you out the window and have you die.
A slow,
horrible death bouncing off fucking shit
on the way down.
There's some animals out there,
man.
It's chilling.
You know,
one of the things that I've always said
about the internet that is good as the
internet allows you to see these things
without coming into contact with these
people.
I mean normally if you want to get that
kind of an image and that kind of a
visual,
you have to either go on patrol with
comps or you have to,
you know,
someone has to bring or you get
unfortunate.
You see it,
you know against your will,
but it's because of the internet.
You can go and find the shit out and see
it from the comfort of your own home and
just know,
okay,
now I know this should exist.
No know there's somebody like that out
there because you didn't run it through
your normal life.
You're not gonna meet.
Somebody wants to blow his fucking
brains out with that.
Blow your brains out with a shotgun.
You need to know there's guys that are
out there,
right?
You know,
it waS a competition in movie and um,
and uh,
18 years old,
19 years old,
brad pitt's in the movie were played
runners together as moody called the
cross the tracks.
So I think,
you know,
when you're 18,
you're tough.
So I'm in my porch.
Some jiving around compton,
stopped a hamburger and fries and a
hamburger joint.
This is 1988.
The crack wars backwards or going on,
you would drive it around compton and a
porsche in 1988.
This is nwa days,
right?
Yeah.
So you're 18.
You look at your 12.
I look like I'm 14 yet.
And you step out of a bad ass fucking
car,
bitcH.
Shut ordering cheeseburger.
And this is really nice dude,
because that's when the black guy and
he's like,
you know what's up ricky?
Silver spoons.
Love it,
man.
Love you.
And these really nice black people have
always loved me.
I don't know why,
but they really dug silver spoons.
So anyway,
so we're talking a few minutes later,
I go back to the original mtv cribs.
I go to back to check it,
I go back to check on my car and there's
three guys in my car in your car and I
didn't turn the alarm on.
My doors are open,
my hatches open and they're pulling the
cd changer.
You remember back in the day that you
had like an eight cd changer.
so they're ripped that out.
Oh my god.
Working on my blog,
punk on my radio drivers.
And so I ran over and they were like
cracked out people and I said,
well get out of my car,
get out of my car and that they need to
look at me.
They're like glanced at me and went back
to work.
What?
Wow.
Literally that was.
There was nothing I could do.
What the fuck was going through your
head?
You're helpless.
You were how old?
Eighteen years old.
And they're ripping my blog on guy with
their,
with their screen.
You don't have a cell phone back then
and you paid.
somebody knows the guy that was.
I was in line with ordering hamburger
cheeseburger,
really nice guy.
He comes around the corner when he sees
my predicament and he goes,
rick,
what's going on and go,
these guys are ripping my stuff off.
And he goes,
okay,
I'll help you hold on.
And I watched him go to his truck and
his car and he opens the trunk and he
pulls out a shotgun this big wow with a
pistol grip and he runs up to my car and
he points it at the guys in my car and
he says,
get out of the motherfucking car.
I'm gonna kill you.
And all those
guys got right out of the my car man.
I got my car and he said,
ricky,
you gotta get outta here.
You know,
around here because I might just have a
on youtube.
See,
that's the kind of shit that needs to be
to
wow.
I never stepped foot off the set again
in compton.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
So they just went right back to work.
Yeah,
just looked at me with christ.
But that one got shit my ass,
man.
That guy did.
I wonder if you know,
he was a gang member.
There's a world he had that little
shotgun.
He was a gang banger.
There's a world of criminals that if
you.
You're not from the world of criminals
and somehow know that you fall into the
world of criminals just accidentally
stumbled into it like I did.
Yeah,
you are.
You're fucked me.
You don't.
You don't understand how everything is
working.
The world of criminals does not work
anything like the regular world of
society.
When I was,
when I was 21 years old when I was,
I guess I was like 23 or 24.
I moved to New York from boston and I
started hanging around with this dude
who's a homeless pool hustler and a.
He was a really smart guy.
It's one of them.
He became my best friend.
Did he teach you a lot of pool?
Because she was great at pullman.
He played hIm.
He playing quake with him,
killed me and I'm pretty.
I'm not bad,
but he plays good.
He plays joseph sickness for games and
right now the way I played pool is
nothing like the way I used to play
pool.
I used to play pool of eight,
10 hours a day.
I put it all the time,
but I went from living in a suburban
boston newton,
Massachusetts to.
I'm just mostly doing taekwondo and
competing and tournament's.
That's all I did like throughout my
childhood playing pool.
And then I went from that to living in
New York and not being around any of the
same people and then hanging out with
his homeless pool,
hustler character and then finding
myself in these fucked up situations
with crazy people.
Like I'm taking him to buy crack at
fucking 3:00
in the morning and he's got to and we
were in harlem and he's going to like go
into this place.
I got the room,
I'm going to find the right place.
And he was fucked up and I was like,
what am I doing here?
And then,
you know,
there was a realization that if I got
busted,
if we got pulled over when he was making
a bus,
they would take my car,
you know,
and helping him.
But I liked the guy,
but I was like completely out of my
element.
I was like,
wow,
this is a creepy fucking world that I'm
into.
All of a sudden I'm in this weird,
you know,
crackdown down
thing happen to me against what happened
here.
Uh,
this girl used to date,
her roommate liked crack.
And so,
uh,
she's like,
will you come with me and him because
his car is broken,
you need to drive.
And I'm like,
okay,
what are we doing?
He's like,
oh,
we're just going to a friend.
He's going to pick up some shit.
and I thought there were just talking
about weed.
So I get into this.
I walk into this house with these
patients that didn't get in the basement
in the basement and it's a crack house.
I didn't even realized it was a crack
house.
So I go downstairs,
there's people like crack everywhere.
There's this person at this table and
I'm sitting there thinking,
all right,
I'm the only white guy here are except
for my girlfriend and two,
this is a crack house and these,
this is,
what the fuck am I doing there?
Of course nothing happened,
but I remember that was what it could
have.
I was like,
that's the end of this hanging out with
this girl.
I
remember new jack city.
You got tHe tv hanging out.
Remember when they had the crack
factoring.
That shit was really going on.
Places where manufacturing crack this
milky white.
What's his name?
Pooky.
Pooky member has a great movie.
Fuck drugs or that's the scariest.
People think that I'm like pro drugs
because I'm pro marijuana and
psychedelics,
but I'm pro nothing.
They get addicted to and nothing that
can kill you.
You know there's.
There's shit that you should totally
avoid.
I tell you what to try adderall now.
Yeah.
Well,
according to ari,
I want to try it.
I've never heard.
He hasn't cleaned his house in forever.
Got on one adderall and fuck half of one
adderall and he cleaned his whole entire
place from like amazing.
Like he found trapper keepers from 12
years ago with incredible hulk on it
because I,
you know,
from a middle school kid they kidnapped
or something.
Well,
adderall is supposed to be really
powerful shit.
Robert told me he took it accidentally
once.
Extra say.
Have you ever tried that?
I'm not really a fan of that.
I've never tried it.
I've learned a lot.
When I did,
actually I had a very powerful positive
experience.
I learned a lot from it,
but I wouldn't do it again.
I did not like the way me and my brain
field.
the next day.
My brain was very dull and it felt like,
like the way I described it,
it felt like a sponge where like most of
the water had been wrung out of it.
It just wasn't working right.
I couldn't make five.
Mike couldn't make connections.
Right.
I was in a,
um,
like a starbucks and I was reading a
magazine the next day I was reading a
boxing magazine.
I couldn't read the magazine.
I couldn't read it.
It was a story I wanted to hear about
it.
You know,
I'm always,
always been a boxing fan.
I'm reading this matchup and I couldn't
read it.
I couldn't put the words together and I
was like,
fuck,
I can't read.
Well,
okay.
Whatever I did laSt night to have this,
you know,
fucking loving,
everybody's cool.
Let's all be friends in this beautiful
positive,
enlightening experience the next day.
Like you paying for that shit for it.
I paid for.
And I was like,
okay,
I paid once.
I'm not paying again.
I know there's some shit that doesn't do
that.
I know that as a positive.
It was a positive experience for me.
I realized like you realize when you do
ecstasy,
a lot of what is possible.
If everybody dropped the bullshit,
you realize like how beautiful life
would be if everybody was like super
friendly and happy to see each other.
Like it would be way more fun and way
more enjoyable than it is right now.
And you,
you know,
you realize that you can do your part to
kinda like make it lean in that
direction.
So I think in that way it was very
positive,
but I think those,
the elevated levels of brain hormones
that you give yourself,
when you take that stuff,
there's a deficit like you,
you go up so then it crashes and then
you don't have any left and then your
brain is just like,
oh,
shitty and fucked up until it
replenishes everything on its own.
I don't think that'S smart.
I don't think you should fuck with that.
There's other stuff that doesn't do
that.
Mushrooms don't do that.
I'm scared to take terms again.
I want to so bad.
But the last time I ship for like six
hours straight on shrooms and it was the
most craziest,
uncomfortable,
worse,
you know,
hanging out in the bathroom,
shitty shit.
ANd sometimes they make you shit because
it's like you're eating mushrooms are
getting poisoned,
poisoned,
but they do have bacteria on them.
Sometimes.
They do have.
A lot of them have fungus on them.
They have to throw it up there,
not diarrhea.
A lot of people throw up,
some people's repeat,
some people throw up and that's when it
really kicks in.
Just really kind of strategy.
You were shitting on trips or anything?
I remember looking at the.
I remember looking at the ground,
it was what?
Like a checkered pattern.
I remember the checkers are goiNg up and
down,
kinD of like texts tetris or something
like that.
Like I saw like the heartbeat in the
floor and it was while I'm shitting my
brains out.
You know,
the crazy thing about the mushroom
experiences individuals,
the crazy thing is that the feeling that
you get,
lIke you kind of get it now and it's
just fleeting feeling.
It's like while you're on the mushrooms
you like,
you get it.
It all seems to make sense.
It all seems to fall into place.
It's like there's a failure.
Yeah,
familiar with.
It's also,
there's like this in an enhanced level
of understanding.
It's like all the bullshit that's going
on in your head.
All the insecurities,
all the false assumptions,
all the things that are just like
tripping up the Way you think.
They all get pushed to the side and the
lights all get turned on.
You know?
That's what my experiences have been on
mushrooms,
but no paranoia.
No,
my son had it all the time and every six
times maybe machines are annoyed.
Any anxiety and fucking bad trips and
shitting myself.
Well,
it's.
I think it's when you try to control it,
it's very humbling.
Sometimes I think that it's just too
strong or too,
like you said,
different molds and stuff,
so you're getting ready.
Yeah.
You don't know who the fuck's growing
your mushrooms to.
Right.
Or making your lsd.
You know,
some people you hear stories of like
crazy lsd makers.
I don't knoW what the fuck they're doing
and you're just pretty much fucking your
brain up.
Here's the story,
rick,
that you think it was fascinating.
We've talked about this before in the
show.
The cia used to do experiments on
american civilians in the 19 fifties
against their will,
did a thing called operation midnight
climax where the cia owned a brothel in
san francisco and in New York and they
got these guys are going to get laid and
they dosed them up with acid and ran
tests on them.
That's how the cia.
Totally true.
Can we make that into a movie on here?
Ladies and gentleman?
This is the beginning.
What research do you have?
A rookie joey productions.
Really real.
It's true with operation midnight
climax.
It's the freedom of information act.
They released these documents via
random.
Yeah,
let's do it.
Real shit is crazy.
I know,
right?
But someone needs to do a documentary on
acid because people don't realize it
because it was squashed out.
They threw so much water on the fire.
We don't and all died out so quickly.
We'd all don't realize people live today
in 2010.
Wouldn't impact acid had on the culture
of the 19 sixties.
I mean people really were convinced that
we're all one.
The flower movement of san francisco,
the flower power movement.
Those people were all on acid.
What about disney,
etc.
I don't know.
What about.
What about disney did that stuff?
All lot of people have done acid.
I'm sure he probably did it.
How the fuck do you come with your
mouse?
Unless you do an acid,
it's possible.
Who knows?
I mean,
it might not have,
but I think a lot of people did it
because there was so many people doing
it.
So many people reporting all these
positive experiences on it that all
these rich,
powerful people,
anyone
in a position that would get in contact
with these people that are doing it,
these artists,
they would want to try it.
You know,
kEn keasy and timothy leary and all
those kinds of terence mckenna,
all those dudes that are,
you know,
doing acid back then,
they,
they all wanted other people to do it
much.
Mushrooms and acid and mushrooms.
Lsd.
Yeah.
It's man made.
I mean,
it does exist.
It exists actually in um,
in,
in some seeds of some plants.
A hawaiian baby.
Woodrow I think has it in it or it has a
similar compound in it.
And there's another one in morning glory
seeds.
Morning glory seeds has like a natural
form of lsd.
You can buy morning glory seeds and you
do something to them.
There's like directions how to do it
online.
You make like you like cook them or
something and then you eat them and you
trip your fucking balls off.
Terence mckenna said that his first
psychedelic experience was morning glory
seeds and then he had all this aztec
imagery like he was looking at like
fucking mayan temples and shit through
the cloud of things like banana peels,
licking frogs.
What?
No,
no,
but this is real,
but isn't the banana peel thing?
No.
It's banana peels.
No real.
No.
Frogs are real.
There's certain frogs that produce man
five meo dmt.
Yeah.
They sound on e bay.
I remember a long time ago I was
actually going to buy one just to
experiment with.
They say what you have to do.
You know how to do it.
Yeah.
There's a whole websIte devoted to do
it.
I didn't say that.
What I heard is that you have to like
make you rub them on glass and then
their excretions or on the glass and
then you drive excretions in the sun and
then you scrape it off and smoke it.
Is that.
Is that what you guys would play?
Something like that?
I didn't actually do it.
Oh no,
no.
I was actually.
I talked to the breeder and he was just
like,
I'm going to have a new batch soon.
I was going to buy like three of them,
but then I was like,
what am I doing?
I'm so stoned.
Locked frogs to trip the fuck out.
That five meo experience is a five.
Meo is still legal.
That's one of the weird things.
When I first did five mil,
we ordered it online.
Five meo dmt,
one of the most potent,
more potent than regular dmt psychedelic
drug,
and you could just order it online.
You can get like a vat of it and just
smoke your fucking brains out.
It's way more powerful than mushrooms.
Way more powerful than pot and you can
order it online.
If a candy flipped,
that's where they take ecstasy and put
on one site is ecstasy on the other
side,
lsd.
Oh my god,
what are you doing to your brain?
Candy flipping.
Fuck,
I can't handle it.
I'd see that's.
That goes into those.
Those weird.
Lose your mind forever.
You know,
trips.
I blamed the grateful dead and all that
shit.
Do you think you lost some brain cells
particularly,
but you know,
I think I lost the most brain cells with
that one story I told you about where I
rented this apartment and then my heat
ended up being carbon dioxide from the
gas furnace blowing on me for two years
or a year.
Found out that day and moving out in my
guys like,
you know,
checking over my room,
made sure I didn't destroy it.
And he goes,
what the fuck?
Why is that done?
Covered?
I'm like,
well that's my heat and the gas outtake
for the gas furnace and is carbon
dioxide easily.
There's many nights where me and this
girl would be like,
am I?
Luckily it was such an old house.
It was drafty
so it wasn't like air tight or
something.
You were getting points right?
I think that did the most damage I was.
No,
it wasn't that long.
It was actually like eight months or
something like that,
but it's a different person.
Yeah,
I totally.
Looking back at that,
I think I definitely got some brain
damage.
Mostly with your speech stuttery since
then.
Oh my god.
And I just totally sue this place,
but now it's like,
what?
Twelve years later,
maybe the guy hit the lottery since then
and now you don't know.
You could get paid sign,
go get yours.
So it made you stutter?
Yeah,
kind of.
I think from that.
That's what I remembered the most.
Shit.
Well that one famous tennis player died
like that.
Venus july litas have you die in the.
In this room by carbon monoxide
poisoning.
But my heater just a couple of years
ago,
not too long ago.
A reason to live somewhere where there's
no heat.
Bitch have electric cars
need to heat in California down here
too.
It's so hot.
It's hot as fuck.
But what is better?
Hottest fuck or dry black ice,
you know,
that scares the shit out.
Like hot as fuck.
I like hot as fuck to me is better than
you can't control your car because the
fucking,
the whole,
you know,
highway becomes a,
an ice skating rink.
That's happened to me many times in
boston.
Fucking hates.
But I grew up in boston.
I used to,
I drove every day because I delivered
newspapers when I was a fighting,
doing taekwondo to make money.
I would deliver newspapers during the
day.
Then I would teach classes and train and
then I would go and compete,
so when I would get up in the morning
every morning at 5:00
AM,
a lot of times nobody had plowed,
nobody had done shit and I would just be
on just how to drive.
Unlike skating,
it was like a rink,
like I would slide around corners
sideways on purpose because nobody was
around like I knew how to handle it
after awhile.
But boston bruins fan?
No,
I don't really like sports.
Like sports.
Yeah.
I get bored with sports when I was
young,
the moment I started doing martial arts,
I thought sports was stupid.
Taekwondo,
what's the dIfference between that and
jujitsu?
Talking about.
no,
it was a striking art kicking.
Mostly kicking,
kicking and punching,
but mostly kicking.
That's what I was thrilled when I left.
Judo is throwing.
Yeah,
we talked about that last night.
I told rick he had to kill somebody with
a low jack.
Okay.
I'm telling them that if a dude
not understand jujitsu and he's an
asshole and he has a jacket on,
that's why it's good to learn the gete,
learn how to use the game jujitsu
because you know a lot of times people
were in close and if some guy is
attacking you and he's got a leather
jacket on,
all you have to do is get your hand up
in there under that collar,
deepen that collar on its neck,
and he's a dead man
dead because I'm going to connect on the
other side.
IT's nice to know.
I just need to know that environments
teach you that room and then you just
fuck with skiers all day.
She'd come up here with them.
Big shoes on pitch,
hang out,
snow,
but judo was the scariest thIng.
If a guy's got clothes on,
if you get in there with like some
fucking jimmy pedro type character,
some know olympic judoka to grab ahold
of your clothes,
man,
you'd gone sailing through the air and
coming down on your fucking head on the
concrete.
That's no joke,
man.
His karate pretty useless nowadays.
I don't know.
Karate is definitely not useless.
There's a lot of times if you have a
black belt in karate though,
it depends on who you're getting it from
and there's a ton of different styles of
karate and even within those styles
there's,
there's instructors that are much more,
you know,
they're,
they're much more pure with their
technique there.
They're better.
They're,
they've,
you know,
they've competed in like international
and world tournament's and you know,
you're always going to get levels.
There's karate guys like machida that
are machIda's a bad mother fucker and
his base,
his karate and he does the best things
about karate.
He,
he's got a wide stance.
He stays back on the outside counter
attacks.
he knows how to leap in and leap out
very difficult to time because of that
and very good at like leaping it almost
like a fencer and tagging people.
he fucks people up,
man.
And that's karate.
He's used it for real,
but he's excellent at it.
That's the thing.
It's like karate is not the best martial
art,
but if you get really good at karate and
then learn the other shit,
you learn,
boy tie how to check kicks at it,
throw knees,
how to,
you know,
take a guy down and choke him.
You learned some jujitsu techniques,
fireballs,
fate.
If you learn all that stuff you can add
to it.
But the thing about like karate that
makes it interesting is that not that
many people are doing it.
so if you get a guy who's a really good,
like really good,
lIke a,
like there's a bunch of different
styles,
but kyoko shin is one that's a real good
one to show to cons.
Another one.
The shogun guys tend to be more like
leap in and I like the drunken drunken
monkey style.
Yeah.
Drunken monkey costume.
That's real.
That shit.
One of the chinese tried everything man.
You know,
they tried all kinds of different
fucking animal forms and grasshopper and
tackle like a praying mantis and fucking
poke you with your fingers and shit.
Chinese were like the most innovative
coming up with different techniques for
fighting.
What about this old school wrestling
like you know,
roman greco,
greco,
roman wrestling?
Well,
it is in the fact that it's grappling.
It's,
it isn't the fact that you're,
you know,
you're still controlling a person's
body,
but the intent is different.
What is no end point?
It's well,
it is.
They beat the fuck out of you.
Wants to hold you down.
Think about a wrestler is once they get
you on your back,
you're fucked.
You know,
they're,
they're used to.
Their whole life has been dedicated to
holding guys down and putting their
shoulder to getting them.
Yeah.
So when they get on top of you and
they're punching you,
they're holding you down and they're
punching you and they're beating the
fuck out of you or some of the most
dangerous fighters in the world of
wrestlers because the fact they have the
ability to dictate where the fight is.
Take where the fight takes place.
If they decide to take you down,
they take you down and if you want to
take them down,
you can't.
They're better at wrestling than you,
so you're fucked.
So you have to do what they want to do.
If he wants to fight on the ground,
you have to find the ground.
If he wants to stand up,
you have to stand up.
It's a huge advantage.
So shoot.
Yeah,
he's a wrestler.
Yes,
definitely.
Bread recipe is a big part of mma.
Lesnar was a wrestler,
so it's his number one skill.
Brock is learning submissions was
getting better with submissions.
He's an incredible athlete who's
learning?
Striking.
He's getting better at it,
but his number one skills wrestling
number one for sure.
Well it's always really good.
I was really good at taking guys down.
It's a big,
powerful fucking athletic guy who's got
excellent wrestling technique.
He's learning all the other stuff.
Wrestling's number one thing it sounds
like.
Yeah.
You just gotta understand jujitsu so you
don't get trapped.
You don't get caught into certain
techniques because some guys were
fucking dangerous off their back.
Like eddie eddie's very dangerous off
back whenever I wrote with eddie.
I only rode with them like,
you know,
not that often,
but every time I think I'm safe when
he's on his back and he catches me with
something.
So like his legs are so dexterous.
He really knows the insides and outsides
of each and every position,
but a lot of guys don't have that.
You know,
there's only a few for breaching
overdoing.
The guy just tapped out.
Fader or he's got that to even higher
level.
His guard is nasty.
There's guys that you just,
you can't get comfortable with you if
you're on top of them.
You can't get comfortable with,
you know,
they're always attacking.
They're always setting you up and
they're always moving.
One step ahead of you.
Use zig when you should have zagged.
All of a sudden,
bang,
we got a triangle locked on,
motherfucker.
You're fucked.
Then you're trying to battle out of it,
but he knows which way you're going to
go because if you go that way,
he's going to counter you by holding
your leg and,
and pulling that up.
And now he aTtacks your arm,
then he attacks the triangle.
Next thing you know you're fucked
because he's just got this high level
shit.
But unless you're fighting those guys,
the most wrestlers are going to be able
to pin a guy down and hold them down.
So huGe skill to hAve.
But I mean you must outweigh eddie by 40
pounds.
No,
not that much money.
And he's like one seventY,
85.
I think eddie's like one 65.
I bet you he's one 65.
So what do you want one 85?
One 90 2:25
pounds.
And I'm a lot stronger than him.
He's big and man I can't tap 'em I've
never tapped him.
I don't think I've ever even come close.
well I've only made him struggling of.
I've never made them like real one day.
Will you?
Who knows,
Is it ticklish?
Most likely he'll tap me again.
I don't do it nearly as much time into
it as he does.
He teaches classes everyday and he
trains everyday.
You know,
he's training when he teaches classes
four nights a week.
He's got a knee injury right now.
So he's not training,
but uh,
when he does,
he's always rolling.
He rolls constantly.
I,
I'm lucky I'll get three days a weekend
if I'm lucky and teaching to teaching a
lot of guys,
lIke there's a dude named brent at our
school who was really good,
but then he started teaching and he
became great.
There's something about teaching people
when you really dissect the techniques,
like they say that one of the best ways
to improve your jujitsu game is to teach
it to somebody else that,
that tall light skinned black guy.
No.
Brent is a heavyset white guy.
Okay.
Big really smart dude.
And he's a brown belt under eddie and
he,
he's a high level brown belt.
When he first started out,
he was just a regular guy,
you know,
just another dude who,
always good.
He was talented,
but when he started teaching also need
to start taking off.
You know,
he's a handful,
very dangerous guy and every time I roll
with them I'm like,
whoa,
there's this certain guys that you roll
with it.
You just gotta watch your p's and q's.
This guy's trying to kill you.
One thing I learned real quick was
you're either all in or all out,
two hands in or two ends out.
If you got one hand in,
you know if,
if if you're on top and you put one hand
in,
they can somehow try.
They can show that.
Yeah,
you can grab your,
grab your arm and trap it.
You gotta be all in,
right?
Is that true?
Yes,
but you know,
even all in,
you've got to be careful.
If you get a guy like for overdoing and
he controls both your wrists,
you're fucked.
You got a lot of problems because he's
going to attack both ways and as you,
as you defend one way,
He's going attack the other way.
You know as If you control your risk at
all,
you're fucked.
It's very important.
You get risk control.
Jujitsu is a such a tactical,
fun thing to do because as you do it,
it's very frustrating.
It's almost like you remember when you
started doing standup comedy and he said
the frustrating thing is that there's no
end to this.
It's like,
it's like it's going to go on forever.
I'm going to take forever to get good at
it.
Know it's just a lot of devotion to
something that you know you're going to
have to go on forever.
It's going to take forever.
You see a guy like joey doc,
how the fuck am I ever going to get that
going?
It's going to take 15 years for me to it
for that.
Now that's the same feeling with
jujitsu.
When you first start out,
you have to enjoy each little miniature
battle that you win every every new
lesson that you learned,
but the most humbling thing about it is
as you do it,
you realize how little you know.
There's so many guys that are so much
better.
There's just,
I'm like decent,
but there's so many guys that were all
talking about marcella garcia last
night.
He's the one of the best,
probably the best grappler in the world.
Really technical.
Not like this broodish powerful guy,
but just all technique and he says
prezilians dude,
super,
super smart and super nice guy too,
and just fucks everybody up.
There's vIdeos of him online.
Just smashing guys,
just taking these really high level
wrestlers.
Really tough guys are just running.
Just choking him,
choking jujitsu that okay.
Over and over and over again.
You know,
and watch this guy just running through
people.
I'm in full guard like when somebody has
got me when I'm above someone and
they've got ms.is
it called?
They've got me in full guard when
they've got you in the garden,
in the garden trying to.
I don't even have a good movie.
You had to break out of the guard to get
onsite control.
You don't know.
Well,
I can show you some stuff.
There's a bunch of different techniques
and you have a few go to moves.
Yeah,
gun by gun man.
It's a game.
If you treat it,
it looked.
If you treat it like penn and teller did
this thing on martial arts where they
said that you're better off saving your
money and then giving it to the mugger.
SavIng the money that you would,
but it's not about not getting mugged,
but martial arts are about is like it's
a very,
very difficult thing that makes your
character stronger.
When you learn martial arts,
when you're doing,
as you're doing this incredibly
difficult thing and when you do that you
learn about yourself and other things
become easier.
It's humbling.
It's very humbling.
It's humbling when some guys that you
know,
you,
you look at him,
it doesn't look like much,
but man,
you're tapping now.
It's humbling too.
It's a,
it's a freaky feeling.
so freaky feeling to have guys dominate
you.
And iT's a freaky feeling to dominate
guys too.
It's a weird feeling.
It is better,
but it's weird to feel people nervous
and freaking out and like when they
first start doing it and shit and
there's like,
you know,
they think they're tough guys and then
they realize like,
you're closing in like,
this is getting to a position where,
fuck,
I'm not getting out of this.
You know,
you've got the dude mountain and he's
bucking and just trying to explode all
his energy,
but every time you do it,
you counter,
nope,
not going anywhere,
stay squash,
and you start slowly squishing them and
squash them and you feel them panicking
is feeling.
Start to freak out when they like,
they don't want to admit that you're
going to kill them,
but that's really what it is.
They have to tap out and you have to
say,
okay,
you're going to give you.
We're just going to kill me.
Right?
Thank you for not killing me.
And then you go again.
That's the craziest game ever and as you
get better,
as you get better at it,
you understand that it's really all
about focus,
focus and energy and trying to put all
the techniques together,
but then once you get them all together,
like once you drill them all and you get
them as a part of your repertoire,
then it just becomes this crazy zen
thing where you don't even know what
you're doing.
When you're doing it,
while you're.
While you're countering and attacking
and everything.
It's like at all like it all plays
itself out,
so it's like you drill,
you drill techniques to a certain point
or when you're rolling they all just
come out and natural.
Then it's crazy fun.
That's really fun and especially when
you go with another guy who was really
good too because you're just battling
back and forth and countering back and
forth and you don't even have time to
think.
You're not thinking about your bills,
you're not thinking about shit.
You know,
thinking about you know your dog.
You're not thinking about your tire that
you're,
you're there in that moment,
but like in a zen way where you're not
even thinking about yourself isn't so
difficult.
you don't have the time to wander on
your bullshit.
You have to keep your eye on.
This guy's trying to choke the fuck out
of you again.
Have you been brian?
No.
I just,
I like croquet and it's not for him.
He likes cats,
cats and croquet,
and it's not for everybody,
but I knew it would be for you.
I'm glad you're doing it.
I knew it would be for you.
Totally loving them.
Loving it because especially when you
tell me stories,
we went to dinner over his house and he
tells me stories about trying to jack
dudes and fucking backing up into him on
the highway and getting crazy on venice
beach is the story I told you about?
Yeah,
you told me that story to my wife and
kids driving down venice beach and I'm
on a bike and this other kid on a
skateboard,
20 years old,
we kind of bumped into each other by
accident.
NoboDy's fault.
And so we kind of untangled each other
from each other and I just decided to go
on my way and as he's leaving he's like,
you stupid motherfucker get out of my
way next time and he's like 20 years old
and I'm like,
fuck you asshole.
And immediately he turns around and he's
like,
I challenged him,
I guess by saying that.
And immediately he turns around,
but he's got like four friends With him
all 20 years old.
And my wife was like,
rick,
what?
You're such a dick for responding to
that.
And I'm like,
well how can I not?
I mean,
the kids 20 years old,
I'm 40.
You don't treat people like that,
you know,
and in the world,
but you gotta you gotta I understand
that,
but you've got to recognize that these
kids,
a lot of them have nothing to lose and
their reputation means too much.
The reputation means anything.
So if you're not around kids like that,
if you,
if you challenge the kid like that,
like he was in la,
I didn't consciously though do it
instinctual just to respond.
Correspond on the worst.
I'm captain,
caveman when any issue like that.
I have to fight off every.
That's my biggest.
That's my biggest weakness actually.
it's essential.
It's natural reacting instead of
responding
legally.
It's not an issue,
I don't think because he's fucking with
you.
You know he starting with you and fuck
That'S not the issue,
but the issue is your,
your health and safety.
They could just ask you or got you
situation.
Well,
it doesn't matter for sure for sure.
It really not even jujitsu because you
don't want to grapple with the garlic
that you want to fucking one tomb.
You want to put them to sleep and then
charge it the next guy and just let them
know,
this is how quick I can put this due to
sleep.
I'm going to get you next because that's
the last thing anybody wants is one dude
knocking out everybody,
so when the.
When.
If you have to attack somebody,
you're better off.
Way better off learning how to strike.
You don't want to let go.
yeah,
watch me pull guard,
bitch,
fucking soccer,
kicking you in.
Not the best thing to learn.
If there's a bunch of people,
the best thing to have is fast fucking
hands.
You'd be able to just light somebody up
just cause you want to somebody,
especially in the street,
especially if they don't know how to
fight.
When that punch actually lands pop,
bam and their eyes roll back in their
head.
They're not even going to expect a that
you're gonna.
Be able to hit him that hard,
be they're gonna.
Be able to do it that quick,
like most dudes have never really.
Boxing never really been punched,
you know,
so if you can just find one dude and pop
bank,
just put that to sleep.
The other guy was going to go,
oh fuck this.
Then you can get them to scatter,
but if you try to do some jujitsu,
they should have a movie like like the
credit card.
But for jujitsu,
the jujitsu kid where the guy says
really good at jujitsu,
got like this little kid could make it
more like a judge into art.
It's kind of weird and the jujitsu is a
real martial art in the sense that you
can defeat a much bigger,
stronger,
more athletic person.
It's very hard to do that with striking
like you can.
It can be done if a guy's an elite
striker and he's facing goes.
Not elite stryker.
That's much dan henderson,
right?
Lead striker.
Dan henderson is really a wrestler.
He's a very powerful striker,
but he's not in the line of st anderson
silva.
Anderson silva is like an elite striker.
He's.
He's a guy who really knows the
intricacies of the standup game dan
henderson does as well,
but you know,
he's more known as a wrestler because I
saw him take out that british guy with
one punch.
Well,
he can knock anybody's best paint.
Yeah.
He's got super power in his hands.
He can knock anybody.
He knocked out vandelay silva with one
punch.
He's knocked out a lot of guys with one
punch,
you know,
but then he's not known as a striker.
Right.
He's not known as like a technical
strike.
What about chuck ladell?
Yes.
He's,
he's a striker.
Is he fighting again?
I don't know.
I think he has made you think so.
Yeah.
Maybe you know,
it's your time becomes up when it's up.
It's up.
He had one of the greatest careers of
all time.
You know,
I just think it's,
think at a certain point in time you
have to be concerned about your health.
You know,
you have to be concerned about,
you know,
how many knockouts you take and you
know,
concerned about your future here.
This is fucking incredible,
amazing career.
The problem is,
you know you have that kind of a fire
burning inside you.
It's very difficult to turn that shit
off,
you know,
very,
very difficult to turn that shit off.
Those guys like you,
they're not.
They're there.
Their whole fucking system is wired for
competition.
Host system is wired for combat for the
moment,
for getting to that cage under the
bright lights and performing,
you know,
their whole self esteem is based on
their ability to rise to a place that
most men can ever get to.
Do you think they could transfer that
easily?
TheY're like,
start playing video games or start doing
something else.
I don't think we as civilians could ever
Possibly understand the highs that it
must be.
When chuck liddell fucking throws his
arm backs and it's pushing his chest out
and screams after he knocks people out
of.
After he knocked randy coture out,
let me ready to go into is one of the
baddest motherfuckers on the planet and
he connects.
Bam and randy goes down and that high is
probably cocaine times a billion.
It's prObably insane.
It's probably.
He probably never feels more alive.
He probably never feels more energetic,
more fulfilled.
This incredible eight week training camp
everyday,
waking up for this one moment and
finally it comes against one of the
baddest motherfuckers on the planet in
front of 16,000
people in a fucking arena.
Everybody's going crazy.
Your punch connect.
They live for that moment that they live
for.
It was nutty and they strap the belt on
him and then they asked them,
you know,
so what's next?
Anybody?
I don't care.
I'll fight anybody.
I'll find anybody in the world like to
fight.
It's hard to step down from that,
I think.
I think that's a,
that's a full copy of highlight.
You haven't comedy.
Comedy is more just fun.
We're having a good time,
but aren't as much as to.
yes,
you sure you have fun.
It's a different kind of high though.
It's,
it's,
um,
it's not nearly as is crazy.
It's not nearly as primal.
It's more fun.
Enjoyable.
Everybody havinG a positive experience
together.
We're all party and we're all having a
good time.
You know,
I'm telling you some comedy.
You're laughing.
We're enjoying our time together.
It's all fun.
Fighting is much more,
you know,
you trying to master something and it
just so happens there's an audience
there watching it,
but it's totally different experience.
Very inward.
You trying to overcome some guys
physical strengths and you impose your
will on him and pose your conditioning
and your preparation on them.
It's like wake ways different way.
Crazier comedy is like everyday normal
bullshiT to me.
I can go on stage right now if there was
an open mic right next door and then you
know,
while we're doing the podcast,
someone said,
hey joe,
you want to do 10 minutes?
I'm like,
yeah,
I'll go.
I'll go,
I'll go up.
I'll just go up and start fucking I'm
what's up,
what's going on?
And I'll just start doing standup.
Just going into mack.
I couldn't go fight,
you know,
couldn't say,
hey,
do you want to cage fighting?
Ten minutes.
I'd Be like,
no,
I need like 10 months and I got to talk
to my mom.
Fucking get a nutritionist,
man.
I gotta make sure my strength and
conditioning programs in order.
Fuck,
who am I fighting as he was driving a
wrestler?
I gotta prepare my,
you know,
what am I going to want to fight a
striker?
How I get fucked up.
You knoW,
you,
you know,
are you going to a scarier.
Where's it going to play you?
No.
Why not?
Because it's not healthy because I must,
I must want to fight.
He must to fight to do it.
I did a lot of competition.
Martial arts competition was young where
I enjoyed it,
but I got out of it without any
complications physically because of
injuries are knockouts or anything like
that,
but I knew people who did.
I know people had complications.
I knew people who had brain damage for
sure from boxing and it's compromised to
how they talk and it's compromised how
they can think and make reason,
reasonable decisions.
I've met people like that.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with fighting.
I don't think we're all,
we're not going to live forever and I
think every man should be allowed to
make his own decisions as to what he
wants to do and how long he wants to
compete.
And you know,
how many knockouts he wants to take and
how much risk he wants to put his body.
It's up to you.
It's your choice.
Why is it,
why is it that you can go and do
motorcycle riding?
You can run betWeen the fucking lanes
and traffic and that's okay.
But you know,
you can't,
you a guy can't get knocked out more
than three times.
He can do whatever the fuck you want.
But for me,
I think um,
I think if you were going to put
yourself at risk,
there should be an end point to it.
And to me it's like what are we gonna do
with it and be the best guy in the
world?
No.
Am I going to win a couple of fights?
What's it going to prove?
You know?
Well,
you know,
the thrill of competition.
Yeah.
And maybe getting your fucking face
broken again.
You know,
maybe getting.
I've had my nose fixed recently and it's
fucking awesome.
I love having my nose again.
Great.
My whole life I'd have fucked up jammed
up nose.
I broke my nose falling down a flight of
stairs when I was five and then I've
been kicked and punched in the face.
I don't know how many times my whole
life,
so it was all fucked.
But what's cool is you don't have
anything to prove.
You know,
we don't need because you are tough,
but that's silly.
There's a lot of people out there that
can kick my ass.
The needing to prove thing.
It should all be,
you know,
you should.
No one should need to prove anything.
And if you do need to prove something to
you,
you can just find out more about
yourself.
You know,
when you need to prove something.
Like this guy's out there that are
trying to start fights or guys that are,
you know,
people that have a chip on their
shoulder.
What they need to do is get more
positive experiences in their life,
get more things would they have
accomplished their emotion,
but they've conquered their emotions and
accomplish the goal.
That seemed really difficult to do.
And they understand more about
themselves.
And that's one of the things about like
mma fighters,
like some of the best guys in the world,
they're super friendly.
George st pierre is one of the nicest
people I have ever met in my life and
he's one of the baddest motherfucker is
pound for pound on the planet and saying
he's so kind and so friendly and
genuine.
And the reason is he doesn't have
anything to prove to anybody.
He proves it to himself in competition.
He proves it to himself in training.
He proved it,
proves it to himself with discipline,
forcing himself to do the hard work to
become great.
And he is great and recognize as great.
So because of that,
he's balanced and he's like super
healthy,
super calm person to be around.
A couple of years ago I watched him
fight against that brazilian guy and it
was a great fight.
Thiago silva and I think elvis rather.
Excuse me.
It was a tie striker.
Yeah.
That guy was strong.
Oh yeah.
And he couldn't sell them.
That's a monster.
St pierre couldn't submit them.
Now the distance I hope has is he's a
beast,
but he has a problem making weight,
didn't make weight for his last fight.
Again,
rematch with john fitch and he didn't
look that good physical.
He looked like he looked like he was a
little hurt by the weight cut because
he's so big in real life.
He's supposed to fight at one 70,
but he walks around over 200,
so he's cutting.
He's dehydrating himself like 30 pounds
and then try to replenish himself and it
just you.
There's going to be a point of a point
of diminishing returns where you cut so
much weight and you dehydrate yourself
so much that your performance is going
to suffer.
Yeah.
He's just so big.
He was giant.
Giant for one 70.
They're gigantic.
He's a fucking bull of a man.
You know?
He's just gOtta lose some weight.
It's got to lose some muscle.
She had too much.
What's so fuNny?
A bowl of it,
man.
That's what he Is.
He isn't bowl.
What would you call it?
The power.
What would you call them?
And very nice gentlemen.
Nice gentlemen.
Yeah,
he's a nice gentleman.
A flavor of muscles.
I saw this picture of a chimp carrying
fruit.
It was an old female chimp and she had
fruit in her hands and fruit and her
feet and she's like carryIng these
things and she's like flexing.
And I looked at him like,
holy fuck.
Have you ever seen like a full grown
male chimpanzee or female chimpanzee
full grown?
How big their fucking arms are?
Holy shit.
That's scary.
Just muscle gigantic.
Her arms were gigantic and they're that
crazy sinewy chimp muscle too,
which is nothing like human muscle to
fucking trippy photograph.
When you realized that chimp could just
beat the fuck out of you.
Remember that one time?
She wants it.
That girls face off.
That was brutal.
Talk about chimps every week.
My friend went to sturgis motorcycle
rally.
Joe.
Yeah.
The whole time she's there.
Uh,
I think like four or five people died
and within like two days and the guys
that people at the thing say,
you know,
this happens every year.
People die like almost every day.
And the last day she Was there,
uh,
this guy was doing the,
where they rub up the engines really
fast or whatever it's called.
I forget what it's called,
but it's like they're just revving of
their engines with us.
Something happened in his motorcycle,
blew up and he got decapitated.
Some flew out of his engineering
capital shit son.
I'm thinking this is how dangerous
motorcycles are.
Fucking how many people die at this
motorcycle thing.
But yet there was a car show for
everyday,
for the last 50 years in burbank.
And no one's ever done it.
The thing about those motorcycle shows
is that a lot of those dudes,
they get crazy and they want to show off
for each other.
Start they start standing on their
bikes.
Ever seen guys surf with their
motorcycle?
Yeah.
There was this old dude was a motorcycle
maker.
I forget his name.
He's a famous guy,
but he was famous for being able to ride
his motorcycle,
like a surf board.
So you'd get that bitch on the highway
level that goes out and then stand on
top of it.
And he was standing there and if he fell
he fell.
And that's a wrap son that called ghost.
What you get when you're doing that?
Well,
no helmet to.
Oh no helmet.
Excuse me.
So stupid.
So he's just living out there on the
edge and they just lost it.
And maybe that's the way you wanted to
go,
you know,
who knows?
I mean and everybody kind like recognize
it.
People didn't make fun of them and say,
oh,
you fucking idiot.
That's what you deserved.
Everybody said,
hey,
died doing what he loved,
I guess.
Okay.
I mean,
what,
you know really realistically,
what are you going to live forever?
I think there's this news cycles that
looked like snowmobiles are crazy.
Look one in the rear and two in the
front.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Something like that.
It's so weird looking and it looks like
a snowmobile.
I've seen that.
It's supposed to be wicked fast.
Yeah.
Can you see that ariel?
Adam,
you've ever seen that thing?
It's like a car.
You ever seen it.